[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver pour le retour des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
après deux semaines de suspension des
travaux parlementaires
les sénateurs vont se retrouver face à
l'exécutif pour ce temps fort de la
semaine est la haute assemblée une
séance qui débute à 15 heures précises
et que l'on va vous décrypter avec notre
équipe de journalistes fidèle au poste
avec nos steve jourdain dans l'hémicycle
du sénat alors style quel est le
programme en cette journée de rentrée un
peu de co vite beaucoup de social tam il
sera notamment question du pass
sanitaire annoncé souhaiter par des
manuels ma compo après le déconfinement
bien pouvoir accéder à certains
établissements culturels
on va aussi parler du baccalauréat 2021
généralisation du contrôle continu ou
bien maintien de certaines épreuves en
présentiel sur ces deux points le
gouvernement devra répondre en quelques
instants at il des sujets de
préoccupation très concret également
avec nos alexander poussard salle des
conférences pour toutes les réactions
des sénateurs et des ministres alors
qu'ils allaient vous interviewez cet
après midi alexandre bonjour tam et bien
je serai avec le président de la
commission des lois du sénat françois
noël buffet pour parler de la révision
de la constitution en faveur du climat
et vous allez le voir les sénateurs ne
sont pas d'accord avec le gouvernement
sur la rédaction du texte et on va
d'ailleurs parlé également climat sur ce
plateau dans un instant et enfin avec
nogent m'assieds ça les gens ravis de
retrouver pour et de retrouver tous les
internautes de ta communauté sur twitter
pour avoir leur avis leur sentiment sur
les questions d'actu cet après midi
hewitt sommes très contents également de
vous retrouver après ces deux semaines
de vacances parlementaires
on est on a vraiment hâte de savoir
quelles sont les questions vont être
posées par les sénateurs et sénatrices
cet après midi d'autant que ça y est
sûre locaux vides on en sait un peu plus
sur le plan de déconfinement on espère
cuir à la question sur ce sujet on
espère aussi dans une demi-heure notre
face à face avec laure darcos sénatrice
les républicains et vice présidente de
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation et nadège avait sénatrice la
république en marche alors que la fin de
l'année scolaire se profile on va parler
ensemble du bac
face à la mobilisation lycéenne jean
michel blanquer recommence à lâcher du
lait
oui à des aménagements des épreuves mais
non il n'y aura pas de contrôle continu
intégral pendant débat à 14h30
[Musique]
mais d'abord le grand débat de ses
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
alors que l'assemblée vient d'adopter le
projet de loi climat
la balle est désormais dans le camp du
sénat la chambre haute auditionne
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à 16h45 la
ministre de la transition écologique par
bara pompili une audition que vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne et en attendant on va parler de
ce texte avec quatre invités avec et
didier mandelli bonjour je sénateurs les
républicains de lavande et vice
président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable face avoue daniel
salmon
bonjour vous êtes sénateur écologiste
d'ille et vilaine et en visio
distanciation et qu'ovide oblige nous
sommes avec bettina laville conseiller
d'état directrice de la revue vraiment
durable présidente et fondatrice du
comité 21 et enfin avec amira echirolles
assouline professeur à l'économie qu'à
l'école d'économie de paris et à paris 1
panthéon sorbonne spécialiste de
l'économie du changement climatique et
de la transition énergétique
on va d'abord commencer tous ensemble
par faire le point sur ce que contient
le texte adopté hier largement par
l'assemblée nationale après le résumé
c'est jérôme raté après trois semaines
de débats en hémicycle l'assemblée
nationale a largement adopté hier le
projet de loi climat par 332 voix pour
77 contre et 140 5 abstentions issues
des travaux de la convention citoyenne
mais largement modifié le texte aura un
impact sur de nombreux domaines du
quotidien des transports à
l'alimentation en passant par l'habitat
le combat écologique n'est jamais
terminé
jamais mais avec cette fois nous
marquons j'en suis persuadé un tournant
en entrant l'écologie dans le quotidien
des français et surtout surtout en
embarquant tout le monde en ne laissant
personne sur le côté
côté logement la rénovation énergétique
sera fortement encouragée pour les
propriétaires qui verront dans un
premier temps les loyers jeu les avants
progressivement de ne plus pouvoir louer
les bien qualifier de passoires
thermiques
un des axes majeurs du projet de loi
concerne les transports pour l'aérien
les députés ont voté l'arrêt des vols
intérieurs en cas d' alternative par le
train inférieur à 2 heures 30 la
compensation carbone des vols en
métropole est aussi actée la pratique du
vélo est encouragée avec l'accès à la
prime à la conversion pour ceux qui
abandonneraient leur voiture pour un
vélo électrique et une forte incitation
pour les entreprises à s'équiper pour
les consommateurs un écho score sera
progressivement mise en place sur
l'habillement certains produits
alimentaires ou encore certains services
cet affichage environnemental
obligatoire permettra de mesurer
l'impact de nos achats sur l'état de la
planète à la cantine une options
végétariennes quotidienne sera aussi
expérimenter les bars et restaurants ne
pourront plus utiliser de chauffage
extérieur pour leur terrasse à partir de
enfin un délit descossy décret pour les
atteintes les plus graves et durables à
l'environnement les contrevenants
risqueront jusqu'à dix ans de prison et
4,5 millions d'euros d'amendé voilà vous
l'avez entendu énormément beaucoup de
mesures dans ce texte daniel seulement
votre groupe dénonce un texte qui n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'urgence on l'a
entendue dans le sujet barbara pompili
qui dit au contraire que le texte marque
un tournant
alors s'il y avait un point qui vraiment
est un problème pour vous une occasion
manquée qu'est ce que ça serait dans ce
texte un seul point vous me vous frustré
la piano énormément de points qui ne qui
ne vont pas mais le principal je dirais
c'est la rénovation thermique des
logements ou là on est vraiment dans ce
cas on peut dire à peine une demi mesure
d'ailleurs on peut dire une demi-mesure
quand même puisque il ya eu des
évaluations sur la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre sur cette mesure qui est
la moitié de ce qui était escompté
puisque on considère comme une
rénovation performante
une rénovation qui va vers à b et c et
rien que le fait de mettre le sait ça
divise par deux l'effet de la mesure
donc voilà on n'est pas du tout dans la
trajectoire sur la rénovation thermique
c'est vraiment assez dramatique c'est
une grosse occasion manquée en nombre à
evry
au milieu du gué sur cette mesure
complètement didier mandelli les
républicains à l'assemblée nationale ont
rappelé que jacques chirac avait
souligné dès 2002 urgence climatique il
a dit à notre maison brûle nous
regardons ailleurs
mais depuis force est constater que ni à
gauche ni à droite les efforts ont été
suffisants ce que ça allait avec ses
textes pas complètement je peux
rejoindre mon collègue
si j'en juge par les réactions des uns
et des autres les ong à ses rédacteurs
ce texte est notoirement insuffisant il
intègre ainsi rentrer de mesures qui
peuvent paraître symbolique ou
cosmétique ou pourra peut-être
développer mais mais en tout cas sur les
six titres qui le composent ça n'est en
fait que le prolongement pour certains
titres deux à la fois du projet de loi à
gec de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités certaine mesure vient de
consultation de cette transition
énergétique une innocence vert donc en
réalité enfin entre nous c'est pas le
grand soir
voilà il faudrait vraiment aller plus
loin parce que pour le coup est donc
écologistes et elle regrette l'ambition
de ce texte au sénat
oui je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
puisque ce texte ne prend en compte que
a priori que 40% des impacts si on dit
qu'on peut additionner ce qui s'est
passé avant mais fait actuellement c'est
insuffisant
après la façon d'y parvenir avec des
échéances avec des priorités c'est autre
chose parce qu'on on a aussi un modèle
voilà qu'il faut conforter sur certains
points mais pour ce qui nous concerne
des rapporteurs font leur travail
actuellement on aura l'occasion
d'arbitrer un certain nombre de points
avec les rapporteurs et les différentes
commissions qui travaillent sur tous ces
sujets j'espère qu'on aboutir à des
propositions ensemble qui seront comme
dans le cadre de la loi d'orientation
des mobilités d'ailleurs qui seront
partagées par le plus grand nombre et on
va essayer de parler ensuite un peu plus
concrètement de toutes les propositions
que vous allez faire les uns et les
autres
bettina laville je vous ai présenté tout
à l'heure mais vous savez vous d'où
où l'on vient vous avez été directrice
de cabinet de brice lalonde ministre au
début des années 90 2 vous avez
travaillé car bérigaud avec lionel
jospin sur les questions
environnementales est ce que vous voyez
le chemin parcouru
ou le chemin qui reste à parcourir et
beaucoup nous disent sur ce plateau
qu'il est encore long pour arriver à nos
objectifs
les deux sont vraies le chemin parcouru
est absolument énorme et en fait depuis
quatre ans l'ensemble des lois sur
l'écologie ont fait avancer les choses
le problème c'est que l'urgence à
augmenter et extrêmement prégnante en
même temps que les mesures et donc
l'urgence aujourd'hui dépasse les
mesures même quand celle ci soit
importante et on est toujours dans cette
tension c'est-à-dire entre désir de
radicalité
parce que la situation est extrêmement
grave en matière climatique et
faisabilité acceptabilité comme on dit
des mesures et je pense que tout le
problème vient de là il ya certaines
mesures on aurait pu aller beaucoup plus
loin
il ya beaucoup de mesures dont on ne
parle pas et qui sont très importants
vous savez je suis adepte de ce beau
livre qui vient de paraître sur la
nuance
oui et vous essayez de faire preuve de
nuance de ce que vous nous dites c'est
ça que vous nous expliquer ce dessin des
cas voilà on va regarder avec vous voilà
amirashi relais assouline bettina
laville le dit finalement quelque part
on est toujours en train de courir
derrière un train en marche
est ce que pour vous eh bien c'est une
bonne loi de compromis à lehman à la
fois des propositions de la convention
citoyenne
elle a dû aussi composer avec une crise
économique voire peut-être plus
fondamentalement avec certains lobbys
barbara pont qui s'en est ouverte ça a
parfois été compliqué et bien d'avoir
les arbitrages sur de nombreux sujets
sur cette loi vous avez raison enfin
tous les intervenants précédents en
raison de souligner que c'est une loi
qui est insuffisante
c'est une loi qui va dans le bon sens
évidemment toutes les mesures qui il
figure vont dans le bon sens mais ce
sont de petites mesures c'est une petite
loi en fait on on ne peut que regretter
son manque d'ambition on ne peut que
regretter
était le manque d'unité autour de toutes
les mesures qui sont qui sont contenues
dans ce texte on peut noter l'absence
des mesures qui seraient véritablement
efficace alors ces mesures étaient
absentes de la lettre de mission qui
avait été donné à la convention
citoyenne la convention citoyenne ne
s'est pas saisie de ce type de mesure et
vous avez mentionné le refus des lobbys
il est évidemment toujours extrêmement
important dans toutes les directions
c'est à dire que certaines des mesures
ont pu être favorisée par les
entreprises
parce que c'est aussi favorable à
l'activité économique h et d'autres bien
sûr on était ont été freinés mais ça
c'est le jeu je crois de toutes les
décisions
elle est autre réaction celle de la vice
présidente socialiste de la commission
du développement durable
angèle préville elle est avec vous salle
des conférences alexandre louis ange et
le pré ville alors on a entendu beaucoup
de critiques sur ce projet de loi climat
vous êtes aussi également un peu
sceptique sur le contenu de ce texte
mais quand même est ce qu'il ya des
avancées en faveur de l'écologie et la
préservation de l'environnement
oui certes il y à des avancées notamment
au niveau de la commande publique et ça
il faut le saluer cela dit il y à des
avancées beaucoup trop timide sur
d'autres sujets est carrément d oubli
puisque il n'est pas question de fret
ferroviaire par exemple alors que c'est
un levier très important pour lutter
contre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et ça on attend toujours le prince
stratégiques nationales qui devaient
nous être livrés par le gouvernement au
début de l'année et en attend toujours
alors que c'est quand même comme j'ai
dit un levier très important donc des
manques notamment sur le secteur
ferroviaire
vous parliez de la commande publique en
quoi encore ça va consister
eh bien ça va consister en des
obligations en fait pour ce qui est de
la commande publique de d'être plus
vertueux
donc ça évidemment c'est bien c'est bien
mais ça ne fait pas tout donc moi
j'attendais évidemment mais nous on va
là à voir le texte au sénat et donc on
va être à même de pouvoir agir au sida
ce niveau-là mettre des amendements et
essayer de faire évoluer le texte
donc voilà on est
enfin pour moi pour le moins je suis en
attente de pouvoir agir intervenir faire
entendre au gouvernement des discours à
ce sujet là notamment sur la protection
de la nature sur la protection des
forêts matures qu'il faut absolument
protéger et sur globalement tout ce
qu'on doit faire pour pour être
résilient puisque c'est dans le titre de
la loi et être résilience est
effectivement concilier dr alors on est
alors le but c'est 30% mais alors on est
bien bien loin des 30 % d'aires
protégées
pour le moment donc c'est bien c'est
bien d'avoir d'inscrire sa mais après il
faut que ce soit très suivi cadrés et
que qui est des effets là pour l'instant
on n'en est pas encore là
voilà justement donc le débat
parlementaire va avoir lieu au sénat est
ce que vous pensez que le gouvernement
va pouvoir accepter des compromis pour
améliorer son texte est ce qu'il est ce
qu'il l'a fait sur ces dernières années
sur l'écologie alors ça a pu arriver
bien sûr puisque par exemple la loi j'ai
qu'elle avait commencé au sénat et on y
inscrit elle était arrivée avec treize
petits articles et on n'y a inscrit
beaucoup de choses le vrac en fait c'est
des choses qui n'étaient pas prévues au
départ qui ont été acceptées donc nous
évidemment là pour le coup on reçoit un
texte très lourd déjà et on va voir
chacun d'entre nous de pouvoir sur
certains sujets particuliers d'aller
plus loin d'apporter des précisions
et voilà d'améliorer le texte bien sûr
et j'espère qu'il saura nous entendre et
voilà c'est tout le travail
parlementaire qui va s'engager au sénat
oui effectivement c'est ce dont on a
parlé sur ce plateau désormais que va
faire le sénat avec ce texte la question
c'est que va faire le sénat que va faire
la majorité de droite et du centre
quelles dispositions compte elle
concrètement changer berne a demandé à
l'une des co rapporteur de cette attaque
la sénatrice les républicains martha de
sidra à comps l'écoutant c'est un texte
qui est très large
très vaste rappelez-vous initialement il
comporté 69 articles
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale il a
été voté avec 218 article une petite
soixantaine voté en commission une
centaine qui s'est rajouté en séance
donc vous voyez bien que la tâche qui va
incomber au sénat ce sera assez lourde
puisqu'il va falloir que nous examinions
article par article
ce que cela va avoir comme impact sur le
quotidien
oui didier mandelli les députés les
républicains comptent sur le sénat gelé
site pour de réelles avancées
environnementales sans pénaliser le
pouvoir d'achat des français qu'est ce
que ça veut dire exactement ça veut dire
que comme le disait un instant martha
sidrac nous allons travailler article
par article avec une série d'amendements
sans doute qu'il reste à peaufiner et
arbitrer pour à la fois toiletter le
texte le rendre acceptable
et puis aller de quel point de vue la
fin de vie économies à tous les niveaux
tout à l'heure en gel prévu il parlait
de la commande publique moi je souhaite
qu'on aille plus loin parce que les
collectivités doivent être exemplaires
force publique doit être exemplaire donc
ça veut dire que à la fois sur
l'utilisation de produits issus de
l'économie circulaire matériaux
biosourcés mais également sur
l'insertion
nous allons travailler sur ces questions
là pour aller encore plus loin intérêts
des clauses qui existe déjà mais elle
encore un peu plus loin
alors on va se saisir de chacun des
articles et on va les traiter comme on
sait la marque de fabrique du sénat
notre groupe aussi de façon pragmatique
avec sous l'angle du bon sens avec le
prisme de de la réalité du terrain
le prisme des élus locaux aussi puisque
le sénat a consacré notamment une
consultation des élus l'eau à cette loi
vous avez déjà des retours de terrain
oui en fait ce que ce que ce
qu'attendent de nous les élus mais comme
chacun de nos concitoyens sont des
mesures à la fois compréhensible
la prise de conscience on vient de
l'évoquer également moi j'étais maire un
certain nombre d'années il ya vingt ans
quand on évoquait ces questions mais le
premier mais mes collègues vous regarder
de façon un peu surprenante comme comme
si on était des extraterrestres
aujourd'hui c'est rentrer dans les
moeurs on a fait beaucoup de progrès
depuis des années donc ce qu'attendent
les élus ce sont des mesures ils ont
intégré ces notions et l'urgence des
mesures de bon sens facile à mettre en
oeuvre et surtout accepter par
l'ensemble des concitoyens parce qu'il
s'agirait pas se retrouver comme on l'a
vécue il ya deux ans avec des dés des
retours et des mobilisations violente
sur le terrain parce que des mesures ne
seraient pas acceptées voisine allemande
et gilet jaune face à l'augmentation de
la taxe carbone daniel salmon votre
groupe avec alizée coloriste également
de l'assemblée ont déjà proposé une
quinzaine de mesures en depuis le début
de l'examen de ce texte je vais donner
quelques exemples vous proposer par
exemple est bien d'aller plus loin sur
un certain nombre de points comme
l'interdiction de la publicité sur les
produits les plus émetteurs de gaz et la
mal bouffe ça dès 2022 là où le projet
de loi prévoit seulement l'interdiction
de la publicité pour les énergies
fossiles
autre mesure vous proposer la fin du
trafic aérien lorsqu une alternative en
tgv existe en moins de quatre heures au
lieu d'une limite qui est fixé par le
texte
à 2h30 ou encore vous propose également
une généralisation du forfait mobilité
durable qui serait rendue obligatoire
alors qu'aujourd'hui le texte prévoit
qu'il soit facultatif 1 précisant qu'il
s'agira d'une indemnité donner aux
salariés qui utilisent les modes de
transports propres
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut quand
même dire que le texte il va dans le bon
sens mais qu'il n'est pas assez
ambitieux puisque vous quand même vous
partez un peu de ces mêmes propositions
ce texte je l' ai dit tout à l'heure il
va dans le bon sens effectivement il
aurait été votée il y a 20 ans on en lit
c'est vraiment d'une loi très
intéressante qui va dans le bon sens
aujourd'hui on n'en est plus là on est
plus dans la trajectoire d'il y a 20 ans
aujourd'hui on voit bien que et bien on
est on est un peu dans le mur et donc il
s'agit de savoir comment on va éviter de
faire 15 tonneaux et on en est là donc
il faut avoir des exigences et cette
fois c'est une loi qui a des petites
incitations qui va dans le bon sens mais
à chaque fois c'est on va dire que c'est
mou c'est des incitations alors on va
donner sur la publicité et bien voilà on
va donner le pouvoir au maire mais le
maire a besoin d'être épaulé f1 par le
préfet également et il faut interdire
certaines choses parce que effectivement
on va pas pouvoir se contenter de dire
ah bah c'est pas bien de faire si vous
pouviez changer dans cinq ans ou dans
dix ans ça sera mieux
non il ya par exemple sur les panneaux
les panneaux publicitaires numériques
nous sommes pour une interdiction
franche et nette il ya certaines choses
comme ça où il faut aller jusqu'au bout
c'est comme dans la rénovation thermique
j'en parlais tout à l'heure mais il faut
aller vers des obligations ce qui veut
dire obligations ça nous oblige d'un
autre côté à faire en sorte que tout le
monde puisse y avoir accès c'est à dire
qu'il faut trouver des tiers financeurs
il faut s'arranger pour que les familles
modestes puissent elles aussi rénové et
donc ça va avec la justice sociale donc
c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment un
ensemble et
je pense que dans ce texte on reste dans
des vrais mans dans la demi mesure et
avec des injonctions contradictoires
c'est à dire sur la publicité on
continue à faire de la publicité pour
les suivait et en même temps on dit aux
gens bah oui mais à l'école on va vous
informer les enfants on va leur dire que
c'est pas bien de trop consommer et
qu'il faut faire attention la planète
est en danger et on est toujours sur ce
registre là injonctions contradictoires
et on ménage la chèvre et le chou et
aujourd'hui on n'a plus le temps bettina
laville est ce que vous êtes d'accord à
ce quoi avec ce texte on est face à des
injonctions contradictoires on l'a
entendu parce que tout l'enjeu c'est
aussi et bien bien sûr il ya eu la force
des lobbys mais il ya aussi
l'acceptabilité des français tout n'est
pas forcément évident vous quel est
votre point de vue à ce que le texte
avance suffisamment quand même est ce
que prévoient les sénateurs vous
paraît-il aller dans le bon sens
apparemment ils voudraient aller plus
loin je souhaite beaucoup sedai plus loi
il n'est pas toujours aller plus loin en
matière écologique il faut bien le dire
sauf sur des mesures très précises et si
ça pouvait changer ça serait parfait
lorsque je voudrais dire c'est que moi
je suis d'accord avec le fait que ce
texte ne va pas assez loin
mais il faut voir sur l'origine les
mesures qui sont sortis de la convention
citoyenne était quoi pendant les dix un
peu en chambre c'est à dire que c'était
quand même le personnes qui étaient
alimentés par des experts qui d'ailleurs
se connaissait tous
après il a franchi le cap de la réalité
et la réalité malheureusement c'est
heureusement c'est la démocratie c'est
la confrontation avec des industriels
les collectivités locales les
parlementaires etc
et du coup effectivement cette entrée
dans la réalité l'a amoindri
alors il y a des une manière de pensée
qui est comme le disait barbara pompili
c'est une étape et on va aller plus loin
de toute façon on va forcément aller
plus loin pour la simple raison que ce
texte
il s'appuie sur les exigences de la snb
c'est à dire la stratégie nationale bas
carbone qui de toute façon va
mécaniquement être changé depuis que le
parlement
européen enfin pas encore mes 20 ans je
suppose arich a voté d'ailleurs s'il est
voté il ya moi le louvre la diminution
des gaz à effet de serre de 50 7% ce qui
fait presque 10% de plus qu'il y a 4 ans
et c'était la base de l'ancienne
stratégie nationale bas carbone donc
tours seulement
effectivement il ya des mesures je suis
d'accord avec ce qui était dit par
exemple sur les passoires thermiques etc
non seulement il ya des mesures qui sont
insuffisants mais de toute façon
l'ensemble s'appuie sur une base qui va
être renouvelé et c'est vrai que c'est
ça la marche écologique depuis
maintenant 20 ans je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire le
sénateur quand on était comme j'ai eu
l'honneur une lettre près ans à
mitterrand ou bien être juste pas et
qu'on prenait des mesures beaucoup de
genres alors je peux vous dire de tous
les partis ya nous regardaient comme si
on était de 12 illuminé mais exactement
comme 30 ans avant on regardait du nom
comme un doux illuminés je veux dire
c'est quelque chose qui est là
l'écologie la défense de la nature c'est
une très longue marche le problème
encore une fois est le pardon de me
répéter c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans l'urgence est donc la base de tout
c'est effectivement une éducation des
citoyens mais de tous les citoyens et en
fait le fait de faire comprendre aux
gens cette urgence c'est leur intérêt
c'est vraiment l'intérêt non pas
seulement des générations futures
moi je croyais que c'étaient les
générations futures il ya cinq ans mais
je sais les générations présentes
mireille chiroleu assouline la ministre
barbara pompili estime que l'état a pris
un tournant vert sous ce quinquennat est
ce que pour vous c'est le cas je ne suis
pas d'accord du tout avec cette
appréciation avec ce cas est ce
qualificatif de verre je dirais que le
gouvernement prend acte d'un certain
nombre de nécessité mais nous sommes
toujours
dans cette perspective qui conduit à
faire voter alternativement des lois qui
fixe des objectifs extrêmement ambitieux
madame la ville parler de la stratégie
nationale bas carbone là aussi donc des
objectifs vont être fixés
mais lorsque ces objectifs sont fixés
les moyens ne sont pas en même temps et
ce sont des lois comme celle qui nous
occupe actuellement qui se préoccupent
de donner des instruments de de mettre
au point des instruments qui doivent
permettre d'atteindre les objectifs et
le problème c'est que les lois comme
celle ci ne ne propose pas d'instruments
qui est suffisamment loin tout ce qui a
été dit là sur l'insuffisance des
instruments l'insuffisance des mesures
je le partage il faudrait vraiment être
plus incisif plus contraignant et le mot
pédagogie a été prononcé et je crois que
c'est essentiel la pédagogie n'a
toujours pas été fait et c'est l'opinion
publique a le sentiment maintenant qu'il
va falloir lutter contre le changement
climatique va falloir prendre un certain
nombre de mesures mais ne se rend pas
bien compte de l'étendue de ce qui est
de ce qu'il reste à faire et le
gouvernement maintenant devrait saisir
l'occasion puisqu'il s'agit maintenant
de voter en fin ou de mettre en place un
nouveau plan de relance
il faudrait saisir l'occasion de faire
un véritable plan de relance vert et
c'est à ce moment là ce qu'on pourra
peut-être se dire que ce gouvernement a
pris un tournant vert et bien
effectivement et cela d'autant que eh
bien on s'oriente vers une stratégie
zéro émissions en 2050 ce temps de
galles l'engagement européen est pour
l'instant selon laurence tubiana
directrice de la fondation européenne
pour le climat membre du haut conseil
pour le climat on en est très très loin
ecoutez-la lors de son audition devant
des sénateurs notre objectif devrait
être au moins devraient être dans le
passé d'avoir été de réduction des
émissions de
un point 5 % par an en fait il faut à
falloir qu'on accélère déjà par rapport
à cette norme que nous n'arrivons pas à
remplir puisque nous sommes encore une
fois très en dessous les émissions
françaises ont baissé de 0.9 % par
rapport à 2010 82 2019 est très
largement parce que 2019 a été une année
assez chaude et que les besoins de
chauffage ont été limités donc on est
dans un décalage très grand entre les
objectifs qui sont pris au plan
politique auquel évidemment se massent
aussi complètement et la réalité de la
politique et des changements sur le cas
de votre réaction daniel salmon
on le comprend il ya un grand décalage
nous dit à lens tout bien là entre les
objectifs politiques
la réalité sur le terrain nos objectifs
à long terme nos engagements européens
quelles stratégies proposez vous pour
que l'on arrive à zéro émissions nettes
en 2050 comme on s'y est engagé alors
déjà le 17 mai les groupes des
écologistes au sénat va présenter un
contre-projet parce qu'on n'a pas
entendu parler des objectifs tout à
l'heure effectivement on est très très
loin des objectifs affichés
on est à peu près avec cette loi on va
économiser 12 millions de tonnes de co2
alors qu'il faudrait en dégotant
économiser 112 donc on est très très
loin
donc nous on va présenter un
contre-projet avec un certain nombre de
mesures qui nous amène à respecter ses
engagements non seulement les
engagements du 40% d'ici 2030 mais du
55% qui nous est donnée par l'europe
on s'aperçoit que l'europe qui était
quand même en phase avec cette lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique a
train de se faire déborder
c'est à dire que les joe biden
aujourd'hui affiche des ambitions très
très importante donc il faut que nous
soyons toujours moteur dans cette dans
cette lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique parce que en fin de compte
cette lutte comme on l'a dit ce n'est
pas pour dans 50 ans c'est pour
aujourd'hui et c'est pour notre
génération à nous que nous agissons qui
demande lui envoya des engagements
européens c'est vrai que maintenant la
donne a changé au niveau des états unis
est ce que vous vous souscrivez
aujourd'hui à ses objectifs européens ce
qu'il faut tout faire pour pouvoir les
satisfaire
compte tenu qu aujourd'hui nous émettons
aujourd'hui 11 tonnes de co2 par an par
habitant en tenant compte de nos
importations on le voit énormément de
progrès à faire
bien sûr bien sûr que je souscris ses
objectifs comme chacun d'entre nous je
pense fin aujourd'hui c'est largement
partagée mais ce décalage en réalité moi
je le joli lustres avec le décalage
entre le projet de loi constitutionnelle
qui est forte ce qui est fort puissant
symbolique à l'article 1 ont modifié la
constitution pour intégrer le climat
c'est vrai ces relations ça vous le
garantir en tout cas ce long texte
initial et puis au même moment la
commission va certainement dire même
moment et au même moment où on sort un
texte qui en réalité et est très loin de
l'objectif affiché dans le projet de loi
de réforme constitutionnelle donc le
décalage il a séduit en même temps
illustré par ces deux textes qui
arrivent en même temps quasiment me
réussir la souligner pour vous sur quels
secteurs faut-il agir en priorité
aujourd'hui pour satisfaire ses
objectifs internationaux la majorité de
l'industrie et de la production
d'énergie sont déjà soit très décarbonés
soient soumises au marché européen de
quotas d'émissions négociables
donc il faut agir sur les deux secteurs
qui sont les plus émetteurs de carbone
c'est le
le logement le bâtiment et le transport
et tant qu'on n'aura pas agi de façon
extrêmement ferme sur les déplacements
sur les véhicules et sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
on sera toujours très très loin des
objectifs que nos affiches et le mot de
la fin pour bettina laville qu'est ce
qui est à craindre si eh bien nous ne
parvenons pas à remplir ses objectifs
ses objectifs internationaux européens
désormais alors je crois qu est ce qui a
été dit niet important perdre le
leadership au niveau politique parce que
l'europe depuis 20 ans portent cette
ambition alors quelles que soient les
mesures moi que je salut joe biden
l'europe garde son avance tout
simplement parce que des états unis
parts de beaucoup plus loin
mais il faut continuer il faut continuer
parce que nous donnons l'exemple et -
les pays ça c'est pour ça que c'est très
important l'action de bayonne parce que
moi les pays riches seront d'efforts
mois les pays pauvres qui effectivement
deviennent pendant qu'ils sont des pays
émergents de gros émetteurs et bien moi
ils en feront
il faut quand même pas oublier que pour
la france nous émettons entre guillemets
peu par rapport au monde entier même si
nous émettons beaucoup par tête
d'habitant
mais nous sommes véritablement nous
avons été dans toutes les coop des fers
de lance et ça il faut absolument
continuer c'est un deux voire
internationales et nationales et ce que
je voudrais ajouter c'est que faux pas
du tout pensé que étant donné le
caractère quand même extrêmement
impressionnant des phénomènes qui se
passe en ce moment au niveau
météorologique au niveau de
l'augmentation des températures
on ne va pas avoir dans l'avenir une
certaine part de contraintes et je crois
malheureusement que nos concitoyens ne
sont pas du tout préparée et je reviens
sur la pédagogie il ya merci merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à ce
débat sur ce texte qui sera débattu et
bien au sénat
courant juin dans une demi heure les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vont commencer nos journalistes sont en
place alexandre poussard salle des
conférences
jean mathia est en train d'animer son
émission avec sa communauté sur twitter
et steve est toujours dans l'hémicycle
du sénat on vous retrouve pour un point
sur les grandes thématiques des ces
questions qui débute à 15h dans mon une
des meilleures maintenant à 15h tom
effectivement on parlera de l'assurance
chômage ou plutôt de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui doit entrer en
vigueur le 1er juillet une réforme est
bien dénoncée par les organisations de
gauche et les syndicats car elle
il considère et bien que cette réforme
va pénaliser certaines catégories de
personnes et notamment les jeunes qui
entrent actuellement sur le marché du
travail sur ce point le gouvernement va
tenter de convaincre les sénateurs les
plus sceptiques et puis il sera aussi
question du passé ni terre vous savez
tome se passe sous été annoncée par
emmanuel mathon pour après le
déconfinement pouvoir accéder à certains
lieux culturels le problème est bien
c'est que ce dispositif ne fait vraiment
pas l'unanimité parmi les élus des élus
qui craignent bien que se passer ni
terre soit à terme généralisé à
l'ensemble des actes de notre vie
quotidienne et puis autre sujet autre
thème cet après-midi le baccalauréat
2021 qu'elle les aménagements peut-on
imaginer pour les épreuves qui sont
prévues en présentiel les étudiants et
les syndicats d'étudiants réclament et
bien que l'ensemble du back 2021 soit
passé en contrôle continu en cause la
crise sanitaire bien évidemment la crise
sanitaire et les inégalités qu'elle
engendre entre les étudiants
du côté du gouvernement du côté de
jean-michel blanquer air il est pour
l'instant hors de question d'annuler les
cris de philosophie et l'épreuve du
grand oral peut-être peut-être qu'on
aura le droit à des annonces cet après
midi m et oui c'est d'ailleurs ce sujet
qu'on va consacrer notre face à face
aujourd'hui à la fin d'année scolaire
qui se profile et les aménagements
possibles pour le bac et pour cela
j'accueille deux sénatrices sur ce
plateau
laure darcos bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice tel est républicain de
l'essonne et vice présidente de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation et face à vous nadège avait
bonjourbonjour sénatrice r&d pays le
groupe de la majorité présidentielle is
you ses nerfs des pays du finistère
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure interrogé le
gouvernement sur l'organisation du bac
une épreuve dont l'organisation inquiète
certains élèves enseignants lundi une
centaine de lycées étaient bloqués pour
réclamer le bac en contrôle continu
jean-michel bancaires commencent à
lâcher du lest le dit oui certainement à
des aménagements des épreuves on en
saura un petit peu plus cet après midi
mais n'ont pour l'instant pas de
contrôle continu intégral c'est celui ci
dessous philosophie et grand oral ces
deux épreuves sont les seuls maintenue
pour le bac 2021
mais les syndicats d'enseignants et de
lycéens en veulent pas en présentiel
ils demandent leur passage en contrôle
continu aujourd'hui on n'est pas prêt à
passer les épreuves du baccalauréat
parce qu'on a passé une année chaotique
avec un décrochage scolaire qui s'est
intensifiée avec des cours à distance
qui ont été aussi chaotique parce que la
peinture duquesne appartement
fonctionner parce que la pédagogie
numérique c'est très différent de la
pédagogie avec un professeur face à soi
il ya beaucoup d'élèves qui sont en
grande difficulté et lé programme
l'intégralité des programmes n'ont pas
pu être traités par la grande majorité
des élèves
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer ne souhaite pas lui
bien annuler ces épreuves
selon lui ce passage sur la table des
examens est nécessaire pour les lycéens
je tiens quand même à ce qu'on ne passe
pas au contrôle continu intégral parce
que je pense aux élèves justement vous
savez j'ai souvent dit on passe le
baccalauréat pas pour le pack à l'erreur
et lui-même mais pour ce que ça va
permettre de réussir ensuite et donc il
faut entraîner les élèves à des choses
positives pour eux bien écrire en
philosophie être capable de s'exprimer à
l'oral et de passer le grand oral sur
ces enseignements de spécialité sont des
objectifs pour que tout simplement les
élèves préparent leur avenir
le ministre de l'éducation nationale il
n'est en revanche pas contre des
aménagements il propose par exemple
l'instauration d'une fiche pour
l'épreuve du grand oral qui signalerait
les points de programme non abordées
autre proposition pour cette épreuve qu
une seule question ne soient préparés au
lieu de deux comme cela était
initialement prévu
jean michel blanquer air qui reçoit les
syndicats d'enseignants et de lycéens
dans l'après midi devrait rapidement
annoncer de nouvelles modalités pour
l'épreuve du bac
alors voilà certains
certains lycéens certains professeurs
demandent un bac 2021 à 100% contrôle
continu laure darcos est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cela coûtait non
enfin moi je prendrais tout ce qui est
valorisant pour un bac 2021 valorisant
voir parler aussi peut-être aussi pour
les bts il faut pas que ça soit un bac
bradé même pour même pour nos enfants
sauf que c'est pas bien
moi ce que je demande avant tout c'est
que le calendrier soit mais avant la fin
de la semaine déterminé on a des
remontées on en parlait que ma collègue
de familles qui sont désespérés pour les
enfants c'est super stressant ils n'ont
pas les dates
est-ce qu'en effet il va y avoir quand
même ces deux examens philo ça se
prépare de france est aussi banal de
france est aussi enfin je veux dire bon
on est en train de déterminer un
calendrier assez précis notamment pour
l'ouverture des établissements culturels
autre sujet qui me voilà là on n'est
même pas pour l'instant capables de
donner un calendrier précis des examens
de fin d'année donc je pense qu'avant
tout jeu peut-être que ça a d'ailleurs
ça calmera un peu les esprits si vous
n'avez il a définitivement les dates
voilà après sur la formation continue je
pense que bien évidemment ça va
continuer à progresser parce que on fait
on n'a pas les mêmes les mêmes examens
qu'il ya quelques années
simplement je pense que c'est très
compliqué parce que d'un établissement à
l'autre alors déjà pendant delecaux vide
tout le monde n'a pas eu la même qualité
et de grandes inégalités douala de
l'amour parce que ça marche pas ça dans
certains endroits en en distance yale
mais au-delà de ça même dans 30
rétablissement les barèmes ne sont pas
les mêmes et donc juger d'un d'un très
bon établissement mais très noté très
sévèrement par rapport à un autre un peu
plus souple c'est quand même un peu
compliqué donc je pense qu'à ce moment
là on va remettre tout à plat mais là ce
qu'on veut c'est que nos enfants
puissent passer sereinement leur bac
cette année on a déjà fait ce que vous
comprenez les inquiétudes et lycéens qui
ont vécu cette année encore une année en
dents de scie un mélange de présentiel
de distancier qui ne se sentent pas
prêts qu'est ce que vous leur qu'est ce
que vous leur dites alors je comprends
d'autant bien que tu maman et que j'ai
un nez
un enfant aussi qui va aller passer son
bac de français c'est évident que c'est
une année je dirais presque deux années
compliquées qu'ils ont besoin d'être
rassurés d'avoir leur disait d'avoir un
calendrier mais effectivement les
premières convocations arrive puisque
certains ont déjà notamment des enfants
qui sont en école hors contrat ont déjà
reçu des convocations en fait pour
passer pour passer leurs épreuves
ils ont besoin de clarté ce sera tout la
question que je poserai jean michel
blanquer tout à l'heure qui puisse nous
en dire un peu plus sur un décalage
entre le public vous nous dites et les
parents les écoles en tout âge privées
qui sont pas du tout qui sont pas du
tout été de la même manière et on a
besoin d'équité et effectivement ce sera
la question que je poserai au ministre
tout à l'heure en espérant voir des
réponses claires précises et qu'ils
puissent éclairer les élèves lors d'art
cautionner large et un petit peu en sort
d'une période où certains lycéens ont
décroché il ya eu des enseignants qui
n'ont pas été remplacés
beaucoup n'ont pas pu terminer les
programmes des classes ont dû fermer
est-ce qu'on a su tirer les
enseignements de la crise sanitaire de
l'an dernier est ce que vous jugez
qu'aujourd'hui on a été l'auteur n'a eu
les moyens nécessaires je pense qu'on
avait raison de pas totalement terminée
fermer les établissements
parce que sur le plan purement même
j'allais dire de ce écologique pour nous
pour nos enfants c'était important
qu'ils puissent retourner en classe
moi j'ai un garçon qui maintenant
étudiant au supérieur
ils ont eu que rarement des cours en
présentiel dit maman je me rappelais
peut même plus à quel point c'est
beaucoup plus facile de se concentrer
quand on est en présentiel et je pense
que toute cette génération parler en
effet de deux ans maintenant quasiment
enfin en tout cas un pacte en deux
années scolaires universitaires
ça va être très compliqué pour eux de se
repositionner de reprendre une vie
normale
même en termes d études donc oui on
appris à mon avis on a on a quand même
été un peu mieux dans l'organisation par
rapport à l'année dernière il ya eu
l'histoire du bug quand ça arrive qu'on
a repris confinement moi j'en avais
parlé au ministre je trouve que c'est un
peu léger 2 du coup la commune et la
tuyauterie mines et la tuyauterie
du coup même les quotités local du genre
ils sont pas foutus d'avoir une fille au
truc qui marche etc
il ya même un prêt bugs comme il y avait
une avait eu l'année dernière ça c'est
également en bois sans et pour les
parents et pour les élèves et pour les
professeurs et pour les professeurs je
pense qu en effet et certains se sont
accrochés certains ont même trouvé que
c'était un moyen plus facile de
récupérer des décrocheurs potentiels qui
faisait un peu le caïd en fond de la
classe quand ils sont entre guillemets
rire le répète
par écran interposé avec leurs
professeurs ils ont pu en récupérer
quelques-uns mais dans l'ensemble il ya
aussi un découragement de leur part et
le fait que du coup ils ont l'impression
que les acquis ont été enfin forcément
ex-amant inégalitaire d'un établissement
à l'autre d'une classe à l'autre
donc qu'est ce qu'on va en tirer du coup
comme examen final qui devrait être le
même pour tous fins et ça paraît
étonnant oui oui effectivement l'air
plusieurs pistes sont évoquées pour
aménager en tout cas cet examen final
jean michel blanquer reçoit d'ailleurs
les lycéens
cet après midi par exemple il ya l'idée
de pouvoir privilégier la meilleure note
entre le contrôle continu et le contrôle
final prévenir le jury des chapitres non
étudiées également passé le coefficient
du grand oral de 10 à 5 nadège avait
est-ce que ça ce sont des bonnes
solutions pour pouvoir est bien quand
même préservé l'examen final mais
effectivement lui donnant pas tout à
fait la même place que si on a invité
dans des conditions classiques
alors ce que je trouve intéressant sur
la première notamment sur la première
proposition qui est privilégié la
meilleure note sur le contrôle continu
et le contrôle et le contrôle en fait
final c'est que au moins les élèves vont
effectivement passer une épreuve ils ont
pas et n'ont rien à perdre
voilà ils ont rien à perdre et en plus
cela sur situation d'examen pour la
suite parce que le baccalauréat en fait
c'est juste la passerelle pour pouvoir
aller vers des études supérieures et les
études supérieures en fait ils sont secs
ils auront des épreuves à passer sur
table donc au moins ça les habitués ça
dédramatise les preuves sur table
ensuite sur la deuxième proposition dont
je sais prévenir le jury des chapitres
non étudiées ça permet d'être plus
équitable on peut effectivement après à
savoir effectivement comment on prévient
xavi
lahlou glace ou ce qu'on se mette à du
noir sur une organisation
ça demande beaucoup d'organisation parce
que l'élève ne peut pas arriver stressé
en disant moi j'ai pas vu ça j'ai pas vu
ça j'ai pas vu ça donc vous ne pouvez
m'interroger que sur sa même pour les
lui même pour ceux qui qui pose les
questions sa demande à se réadapter sans
cesse donc ça me paraît assez difficile
de la mettre en oeuvre sauf si c'est
bien cadré et la sai on est sur la même
chose quel est le calendrier et comment
on fait c'est quoi la méthode quoi alors
autres sujets sains celui du bts on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure on écoute et
bien vincent brun garde
il est avocat du collectif bts en
détresse ce collectif qui a saisi la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour réclamer le contrôle continu
il estime que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a fait preuve d'intransigeance
dans cette situation en l'écoutant on va
l'écouter on avait tellement le
sentiment après ce que vous avez une
position de principe
c'est à dire que le gouvernement a fait
le choix du présentiel et donc envers et
contre tous
par principe il souhaite maintenir cette
scène décision il cherche aussi à
maintenir cette décision pour accréditer
l'idée d'une amélioration sanitaire sauf
que cette amélioration sanitaire n'est
pas aussi spectaculaire que ce qui nous
est et ce qui nous est dit et ce qui
nous est décrit notamment par le
ministère devant devant le conseil
d'état
vous avez aussi un pouvoir heavy duty
qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent confortée
par le fait que les contre-pouvoirs sont
défaillants parce que vous avez un
pouvoir législatif qui n'a pas permis un
véritable débat sur ces questions
d'examen en présentiel alors même que
c'est une question indispensable alors
darcos est ce que vous estimez que les
parlementaires auraient dû avoir leur
mot à dire sur la tenue de ces examens
parce que c'est votre rôle en alors
c'est notre rôle mais c'est surtout que
on passe beaucoup de temps à écrire des
courriers aux gouvernements envoyée
parce que les questions les questions
écrites on n'a pas souvent des réponses
instantanées en
mais avec mon ami bruno belin on a été
des dizaines et dizaines de co
signataire justement pour alerter et
jean michel blanquer est également
faudrait vidal parce que les bts ont
cette spécificité d'être à cheval sur
les deux sur les deux ministères on n'a
pas eu de réponse concrète à enfin à la
suite de cette ce courrier bon je sens
quand même que le gouvernement essaie de
faire des efforts notamment sur la
formation continue puisque bien
évidemment les bts en sa spécificité
d'avoir également des stages en
entreprises la formation continue alors
c'est sera jamais pareil
là encore c'est je pense une génération
entre guillemets un peu sacrifié ceux
qui auront fait deux ans de bts entre
l'année dernière et cette année il faut
qu'une énorme alors pour avoir des
stages c'est compliqué alors bien
évidemment du gouvernement a permis
qu'on prolonge la durée des stages par
rapport à la fin d'année civile que
depuis ça puisse être segmenté si jamais
on n'arrive pas à en trouver quatre ou
cinq mois d'affilée mettre en condition
les élèves au sein de leurs de leur
école en fait comme s'il était en
entreprise mais tout ça c'est vrai que
c'est quand même assez léger par rapport
au fait qu'ils auront l'impression
d'avoir été bradée et du coup ce qui est
important c'est ce sont des gens qui
disent à des enfants qui déjeunent
pardon qui veulent être dans la vie
professionnelle assez rapidement et ils
auront l'impression du coup que leur bts
n'aura pas la même valeur aux yeux des
entreprises donc à nous aussi
là par contre de convaincre les
entreprises de de leur dire de quand
même leur laisser leur chance
et voilà elle est de continuer à faire
confiance à cette génération qui aurait
été sacrifié l'un des arguments de ce
collectif de bts en détresse et de 2 en
détresse et de dire ce qu'ils sortent de
bts cette année il n'en ruraux qu'une
année normale ils ont peut-être encore
plus souffert du coc vite et ceux qui
l'an dernier ont pu passer leur bts en
contrôle continu et que finalement ils
ont vraiment l'impression que eux ont
encore plus encore plus de difficultés
encore plus souffert que leur répondre
on peut pas le nier c'est vrai ils
n'auront eu aucune année normale puisque
ils ont été sur une année et demie deux
années scolaires en fait sur la période
qu'ovide on parlait des stages qui est
quand même le coeur de leur formation
professionnelle qui a été difficile à
trouver
parce que les entreprises ont eu besoin
de se réorganiser aussi donc accueillir
des stagiaires ça mais aussi une
difficulté supplémentaire faire du stage
en visioconférence c'est peut-être parce
qu'il ya mieux non plus pour s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle
maintenant je pense qu'on pourrait
peut-être être sur un sur une
proposition comme les la proposition sur
le bac c'est à dire bah on passe
l'épreuve
et puis on voit le contrôle continu et
on voit quelle est la meilleure note de
façon à être équitable aussi sur les
deux diplômes donc mais il est évident
que les bts quand ils vont s'insérer
ce sera dans la vie professionnelle ce
sera un moment particulier avec une
situation économique aussi particulière
ces sujets sains du bac du bts cave
aussi passionné la communauté gens on va
retrouver jean macé notre streamer
politique
ce sujet et d'autres d'ailleurs qui sont
au programme de la séance des questions
d'actualité qu'est ce qui a bien fait le
plus parler de ta communauté
moins d'un quart d'heure maintenant du
début de cette séance de questions et
ben tu l'as dit à mme effectivement le
sujet du contrôle continu pour le bac
fait réagir fait questionner certains
bacheliers qui le prépare ont laissé
stressé angoissé évidemment on pense à
eux et puis il se pose la question de
l'égalité face à l'épreuve c'est quelque
chose qui est important pour eux et
voilà ils entendent parler d'autres
lycées dans le département d'à côté qui
ont eu des conditions qu'ils estiment
être parfois un peu plus favorable pour
réviser le bac le préparer du coup il y
en a qui trouve ça un peu injuste les
conditions d'organisation du bac qui
s'inquiètent pour la rentrée à la fac
l'année prochaine on les comprend et du
coup les attentes de la part des
sénateurs et sénatrices qu'ils posent
des questions à jean michel blanquer et
qu'ils obtiennent des réponses de sa
part des garanties éventuellement sur
voilà l'égalité devant l'examen parmi
les autres sujets qui intéressent la
réouverture des lieux culturels
notamment les cinémas figure-toi les
internautes c'est surtout le ciné qu'ils
attendent avec avec impatience ils se
posent également des questions par
exemple sur eux
oui c'est ça et bien de ce côté là mais
un peu il va finir des réflexions sur
est ce que ce serait pas le moment
d'ailleurs de remettre un petit peu de
boost sur le pass culture tu sais pour
les jeunes qui avaient été promis en
2007 pendant la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron qu'elles aident
également pour les artistes us et les
occupations de théâtre et aussi des
questionnements tôt pour ça donc
peut-être l'occasion pour roselyne
bachelot cet après midi d'apporter des
éclaircissements aux sénateurs et
sénatrices et enfin la question de la
vaccination c'est aussi sans sujet qui
interroge notamment où est ce que le
gouvernement ne rend pas possible la
vaccination pour les personnes qui sont
volontaires mais qui peuvent pas encore
y aller on voit des photos des vidéos et
des témoignages de centres de
vaccination étaient chaise vide ça pose
des questions on se dit mais pourquoi il
y en a certains qui sont pressés ils
veulent ce genre d'accident qui peuvent
aider à lutter contre le président voilà
aussi des questions sur la campagne va
bien merci merci beaucoup jean va voir
si les réponses du gouvernement vont
satisfaire des internautes tout à
l'heure on va très vite aller salle des
conférences mais juste un mot laure
darcos sur la toutes les préoccupations
des jeunes notamment par rapport à bien
à la réouverture des lieux culturels
c'est prévu pour le 19 mai on n'en peut
plus d'attendre mais on sait que c'est
aussi ni très compliqué pour toutes ces
salles de spectacle c'est signer alors
les ouvrir avec ses jauges assez sûr
c'est sûr mais surtout ce qui est
compliqué c'est si le gouvernement a
commencé à le laisser planer il y avait
des différences entre les différentes
régions et territoires
parce que du coup en effet dans certains
lieux culturels il faudrait peut-être
attendre un peu plus longtemps pour les
cinémas je suis là dessus en lien
constant avec les producteurs notamment
ils ont été très raisonnables et ils
vont faire en sorte que tous les bons
films qui sont retardés depuis des mois
et des mois il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
de tournages dans les deux ans de kobe
de finlande mikko vide ne sortent pas
tout ce même jour bien évidemment enfin
le même mercredi est donc en bonne
intelligence sont en train de nous faire
un super programme sur un an
avec toutes les tous les films attendus
par les jeunes et moins jeunes qui se
sait temps d'un petit peu et moi pour
mon plus grand plaisir n'y aura pas de
pop corn et de trucs comme ça à manger
dans les spectacles dans les salles
pendant un bon bout de temps donc enfin
avoir écouté allez on va aller
maintenant salle des conférences en
cette journée de bicentenaire de la mort
de napoléon alors qu emmanuel macron
prononce cet après midi un discours à
l'institut de france pour commémorer cet
anniversaire
alexandre vous êtes avec la ministre
chargée de la mémoire et des anciens
combattants geneviève darrieussecq
oui geneviève darrieussecq et ce qu'il
faut commémorer napoléon alors qu'il ya
quand même des zones d'ombré sous son
empire il a quand même rétabli
l'esclavagé on peut voit quand même nier
que napoléon a été un grand personnage
de l'histoire de france et que nous
vivons encore avec une structuration
sociale territoriale qui qui a été mise
en oeuvre par napoléon préfecture les
départements le code civil
le baccalauréat donc la pole et on est
un grand personnage notre histoire
chaque personnage assez face aux dômes
régalement et je crois qu'il faut voir
tout cela avec réalisme et qu'il importe
justement de montrer toutes les facettes
d'un personnage pas de les cacher de les
dire de façon transparente simple afin
de tout simplement voir que chacun se
fasse une opinion sur
le personnage qui était napoléon donc
finalement ce n'est pas une célébration
mais c'est une commémoration historique
avec une visée historique de la part du
président de la république
je crois que c'est une visite historique
de son temps que 200 ans pardon que
napoléon et est mort le président de la
république à faire un discours cet après
midi va déposer une gerbe sur le tombeau
de napoléon aux invalides et voilà je
crois que c'est un moment normal de la
part d'un chef de l'état qui puisse
honorer napoléon alors je ne sais qu'on
va parler des élections régionales
puisque vous êtes tête de liste de la
majorité présidentielle aux régionales
en nouvelles aquitaine avant de parler
de la nouvelle aquitaine je voudrais
qu'on parle de la région paca et de
toute cette polémique autour d'une
alliance entre le président et les
renaud muselier et quelques membres de
la république en marche qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette polémique parce
que j'en retiens surtout c'est que ça a
été beaucoup de violence verbale que
j'ai pu percevoir avant-hier hier avec
même une violence de l'ostracisme qui se
dégageait de la part de certains
r 10 ans n'iront jamais avec des macros
nice où je vais dire mais c'est quoi ça
moi ce que je souhaite enfin ce que je
souhaite
je ne vais pas m'intéresser à cette
région j'ai assez de la mienne mais il
me semble que notre société a besoin
d'un peu d'apaisement la société fatigué
en ce moment a besoin d'apaisement et
moi j'engage les responsables politiques
à faire preuve justement de
responsabilité et d'apaisement
alors justement sur votre région sur la
nouvelle aquitaine vous mener la liste
la majorité présidentielle il y a
également une liste les républicains qui
emmenée par l'ancien maire de bordeaux
nicolas florian est ce que vous pourriez
vous unir par exemple au moment du
second tour pour battre alain rousset le
président socialiste sortant
wolman objectif c'est de gagner cette
élection je pense qu'il faut
effectivement changer la majorité très
simplement parce que cette majorité
fonctionne très mal qu'il faut changer
également les hommes et les femmes qu'il
faut changer les pratiques dans cette
région donc oui je suis candidate et mon
but personnel est de rassembler je
rassemble de la gauche progressiste à la
droite constructive
gd juppéiste avec moi j'ai aussi des
personnalités de centre gauche et mon
but est de faire en sorte que cette
offre politique très large et bien
montre à nos concitoyens et aux
aquitains que nous sommes en capacité de
prendre la relève dans cette région avec
un projet autour d'un projet sur lequel
nous sommes accordés et en fonction des
résultats au premier tour de ces
élections régionales
est ce que vous pourriez rassembler
encore plus loin avec la liste les
républicains je pense que quand on a
l'intention de gagner il faut savoir
rassembler au maximum
d'accord donc le message est passé entre
les mains merci beaucoup
madame ministre d'avoir répondu à mes
questions merci merci beaucoup alexandre
imbert effectivement on n'annonce pas
d'alliance avant le premier tour quel
que soit les territoires sauf en paca un
mot quand même sur les bases
ce quasi psychodrame qui a quand même
largement bousculé la famille
r hier notamment ça va laisser des
traces laure darcos
oui beaucoup d'émoi je dois dire que
même maintenant je suis président de la
fédération dans l'essonne vraiment des
gens qui étaient prêts à rendre des
cartes je pense qu'il faut faire la
différence entre faire des choix de
personnes dans certains cas où on prend
des personnalités importantes dans des
listes et puis en effet cette règle de
fusion pas avant le premier tour et j'ai
été très triste parce que j'ai vu des
élus de cette région écartelée entre
certains qui disait notre combat c'est
le front national et donc voilà nous
jetait pas la pierre
et puis en même temps de tout se dire
quand même oui c'était très maladroit il
leur fallut attendre le soir du premier
tour
est ce que ça donne l'impression que l
air lrm défi surtout je pense que blanc
banlieue en fonctionnalités que ce soit
annoncée par présente le premier
ministre ou là vraiment on a
l'impression que c'était un piège et un
pillage national et pas simplement que
pour la pac 1 de vouloir des conférences
et qui va répondre aux questions tout à
l'heure des sénateurs je vous laisse
poursuivre non mais voilà donc du coup
c'était s'était en effet beaucoup d'émoi
et pourtant j'ai beaucoup d'affection
pour renaud muselier j'espère qu'il va
réussir à sortir de ce mauvais pas voilà
on a déjà vu votre votre réaction parce
que l'on voit est bien renaud muselier
qui a dû depuis et bien promettre qu'il
n'y aurait pas de deux ministres en tout
cas sur sa liste bien sûr on pense à
sophie cluzel dix ans il faudra même
qu'elle démissionne si elle veut aller
sur m'a dit qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire vous alors que sur 110
ch et lrm il ya des promesses qui ont
été faites avec des places
alors après ce que ça m'inspire moi
c'est que c'est un peu vieille politique
et je serais plutôt pour dire qu' il ya
des compétences partout je connais pas
le territoire de paca il faut vraiment
bien connaître le territoire et savoir
quelles sont les compétences et les
meilleures personnes pour pouvoir
effectivement contrer le
rassemblement national donc aujourd'hui
je pense que si ce choix était fait sur
la région ne la connaissent beaucoup
mieux que moi
et effectivement ils ont dû peser dans
la balance toutes les compétences pour
mener une liste et m une liste en place
qui puisse remporter la région
est ce que c'est un stage dangereux
néanmoins ah oui moi je pense que là on
là il ya une dépassement de ligne rouge
avec avec voilà des accords avant avant
premier tour je moi je reste correct
télé tout le monde parce qu'en effet il
faut se tendre la main au deuxième tour
parce qu'il faut près faut connaître
voilà véritablement son ennemi sur le
call et c'est vrai que on fait tout pour
ne pas ne pas disparaître et on est loin
de disparaître
et donc pour exister vraiment en tant
que famille politique il faut qu'on
puisse affirmer haut et fort nos
couleurs en tout cas au premier tour eh
bien merci merci beaucoup à edf d'avoir
participé à ce face à face on va
continuer à aller salle des conférences
ont 20 rejoindre alexandre qui se trouve
avec françois noël buffet le président
de la commission des lois mais d'abord
un mot sur les régionales n'est ce pas
alexandre oui françois noël buffet qui
on le rappelle l'année dernière lors des
dernières élections municipales et
métropolitaine à lyon avait conclu une
alliance au second tour avec la
république hors marché avec gérard
collomb françois noël buffet qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de toute cette
polémique autour de cette alliance en
région paca que des regrets et que des
inquiétudes en réalité l'absence de
clarté et parfaitement nocives
s'engager dans des aventures de cette
nature c'est à coup sûr créer le gm du
doute et donc d'un vote qu'on aura du
mal à capter et qui risque
malheureusement d'aller ailleurs et pas
dans les bonnes conditions
vous évoquez lyon lyon c'est au deuxième
tour simplement dans des conditions
particulières et surtout en toute
transparence c'est-à-dire de manière
publique que nous l'avons fait là je
trouve que ça n'est pas en toute
transparence ça n'était pas de manière
publique et ce n'est pas bien alors
incontestablement il ya une volonté de
l'exécutif de placer des coins dans les
candidatures et l'air prenons garde à
cela c'est pas parce que parfois on peut
être d'accord sur des actions menées par
l'exécutif c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre de la position de renaud
muselier que cela empêche que nous ayons
nos propres convictions
ils ont pu aussi avancer de façon
autonome donc prudence il faut que les
choses se calment et qu'on se met à
parler du fond et on va parler du fond
on va parler du dossier important de la
commission dès aujourd'hui c'est la
révision de la constitution en faveur du
climat alors pour bien comprendre va
l'expliquer un gouvernement veut
introduire à l'article 1er de la
constitution
la phrase suivante la france garantit la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique et lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et votre
commission des lois françois noël buffet
a modifié cette rédaction
en remplaçant le mot garantie par les
mots préserver et agir quel est le
problème avec cette rédaction du
gouvernement et en faisant également
référence à la charte de l'environnement
de 2004
j'ai proposé cet amendement parce que je
crois sérieusement que le verbe garantir
et notre travail est un travail de droit
d'abord porte en lui les germes de
grandes difficultés face à la
constitution et de doutes sur le
caractère sur son application réalité
donc cela il faut l'éviter
donc nous protéger l'environnement
naturellement que nous sommes d'accord
la charte de l'environnement fait partie
du bloc constitutionnel et donc la
rédaction de l'article 1
le fait qu'aujourd'hui on a une
référence x évidente à cette charte est
donc préserve l'environnement de façon
sérieuse et surtout certaines on évite
le doute
c'est à dire que je ne veux pas
constitutionnaliser le doute
merci beaucoup français ne veulent plus
faire pour votre réaction et on va se
diriger dans la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat puisque sime les
questions d'actualité vont commencer oui
on part un peu de coville est beaucoup
beaucoup de social
alexandre dans quelques instants avec
cette question qui se pose aujourd'hui
faut-il lever les brevets sur les
vaccins contre le coc vide
et bien cette question se fait de plus
en plus pressante une centaine d'états
demandent à l'om c'est aujourd'hui il
vient de lever les droits sur la
propriété intellectuelle concrètement ça
permettrait à n'importe quel groupe
pharmaceutique de produire de fabriquer
ces vaccins pour le moment la france le
gouvernement s'oppose à la levée de ces
brevets la question va être posée tout
de suite au gouvernement par les
sénateurs socialistes la science a
débuté on se retrouve juste après et
distribuer nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation dans l'at il en séance
sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues attentats après attentats nous
avons l'impression de répéter les mêmes
mots d'assister au même cérémonie de
rencontrer les mêmes familles dévastées
par le chagrin
et pourtant ce qui s'est passé à
rambouillet ce 23 avril dernier a
constitué pour la communauté de la
police pour les rambolitains un degré
supplémentaire dans la douleur que nous
avons déjà les sept attentats a touché
dans ce commissariat des hommes et des
femmes qui pour beaucoup d'entre nous et
pardonnez moi même on a cité nous sont
familiers cet islamiste a assassiné
stéphanie m'enfermer que nous
connaissions particulièrement ce crime a
été pour tous les yvelines goy après
magnanville et conflans sainte honorine
la nouvelle étape d'une tragédie qui ne
paraît jamais finir
aucun lieu notre territoire n'est
désormais épargné par l'islamisme
radical
notre seule volonté doit être
l'efficacité dans la lutte contre ce
terrorisme
l'efficacité dans la protection de nos
concitoyens parce ce que certains
qualifient de guerre face à la volonté
de diviser notre nation par cette
violence ne s'est donc pas répondre aux
avec détermination en démocrate en
démocrate solide sur nos valeurs
c'est ce que nous avons réaffirmé à vos
côtés monsieur le premier ministre est
aux côtés des élus présents vendredi
dernier soyons
est terminée c'est notre responsabilité
monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues je vous propose
maintenant d'observer un moment de
recueillement à la mémoire de la ville
qui vend l'unissant à la mémoire de
toutes les victimes notamment depuis
2012 je pense à ces chemins de douleurs
depuis tant d'années
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement notre séance
et retransmise en direct sur public
sénat chacun sera attentif je vais céder
la présidence de nos questions à notre
collègue vice-président rené projet
karoutchi pardonnez moi
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la séance est retransmise
au nom du bureau du sénat
jacquet j'appelle chacun de vous mes
chers collègues a observé au cours de
nos échanges l'une des valeurs
essentielles du sénat le respect qu'il
s'agisse du respect des uns ou des
autres et de celui du temps de parole la
parole est à monsieur pierre médevielle
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues jeudi dernier le
président de la république annoncé la
mise en place d'un pass sanitaires pour
concilier sortie de crise et respect des
libertés individuelles
la vaccination n'étant pas encore
accessible à tous et reste facultative
l'idée de mettre en place un passeport
vaccinale a été écarté au profit d'un
dispositif moins restrictif le pass and
i ter seront délivrés sur présentation
d'une attestation vaccinale d'un
certificat de guérison ou des résultats
négatifs d'un test pcr ou antigénique
réalisés dans les 72 heures il devrait
être obligatoire dès le 9 juin dans les
lieux particulièrement fréquentés tels
que les foires et les salons et à partir
du 30 juin pour participer à des
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
se passera également un pré requis pour
l'accueil des touristes étrangers dans
la tente du prochain débat au parlement
à ce sujet plusieurs questions restent
en suspens pour l'heure l'agencé
européenne des médicaments a reconnu
quatre vaccins à yzeure astrazeneca
monde et renens et johnson johnson
ma première question d'autres vaccins
seront ils acceptés par le dispositif
pour permettre par exemple d'accueillir
des touristes de pays ayant fait un show
vaccinale différent du nôtre
nous aimerions également savoir madame
la ministre
si le pass sanitaire sera obligatoire
pour les mineurs et le cas échéant à
partir de quel âge jeunes au niveau
européen un cadre commun est en cours de
définition
les eurodéputés se sont prononcés le 29
avril dernier sur la mise en place d'un
certificat vert numérique
d'ici fin juin sur l'instauration
devrait permettre de faciliter les
déplacements entre les pays membres
pourriez vous nous confirmer que sa
délivrance se fera dans les mêmes
conditions que le passé ni terre enfin
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur les
conditions de la levée des mesures de
quarantaine
merci madame brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué chargé de l'autonomie
monsieur le sénateur pierre médevielle
merci pour ces nombreuses questions je
vais vous répondre au stade de notre
examen aujourd'hui sur le pass annie
terre et sont les avancées que vous avez
déjà un peu précisé et puis pour le
reste vous savez bien qu'elles vont
dépendre d'autres négociations et
d'autres transactions et que aussi il y
aura un texte que vous étudierez et que
le ministre vous présentera donc je
voulais d'abord saluer quand même la
résilience des français dans cette crise
sanitaire et puis aussi leur engouement
pour la vaccination il ya près de 16
millions de français qui ont reçu au
moins une dose et ça fait 30 % de la
population 550000 injections ont été
réalisés ne serait ce que dans la
journée d'hier donc avec cette
augmentation de doses disponibles et
l'extension progressive des publics
nous atteignons notre objectif de
protéger progressivement toute la
population c'est une condition sine qua
none pour le retrouver la vie normale
le président de la république a dressé
un cap clair dès le 15 juin tous les
français majeurs qui le souhaite et je
l'espère chacun d'entre eux pourront se
faire vacciner
cette situation dure ouvre la
possibilité d'un pass sanitaires à
l'invers du passeport vaccinale qui
n'est pas uniquement lié donc à l'acte
de vaccination mais bien qui portera sur
tout et qui sera accessible par votre
téléphone qui listera des tests pcr les
tests positifs de moins de trois mois
ainsi que les certificats de vaccination
la fascination étant fortement encouragé
le pass and i ter ne pénalisera pas les
personnes non vaccinées contre la copie
de 19
d'autant que je le rappelle c'est assez
unique en europe les tests sont gratuits
en france au niveau européen la mise en
place d'un certificat sanitaire
permettant aux citoyens européens de
voyager au sein de l'union est en train
d'être débattue et puis
plusieurs compagnies aériennes
envisagent également d'utiliser ces
passeports sanitaires pour les vols hors
de la france ces éléments sont
actuellement discutées dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de gestion de
la sortie de crise sanitaire que porte
le ministre olivier ferrand qui vous
permettra de vous prononcer clairement
au sein de votre assemblée
merci ministre la parole est maintenant
monsieur alain milon pour le groupe
l'est républicain
madame la ministre
voilà maintenant plus de deux mois que
l'ap-hm l'assistance publique hôpitaux
de marseille et dans l'attenté d'un
nouveau directeur général
je page 17 ans que voilà plus de deux
mois que la peine marseille et dans
l'attenté d'un nouveau directeur général
les procédures ont pourtant été
respectée de façon scrupuleuse un
consensus local a même été établi
concernant les candidatures proposées
par la présidente du conseil de
surveillance madame rubio là le doyen de
la faculté de médecine le professeur
leonetti par ailleurs conseiller
régional et le président de la cme le
professeur aussi cette situation est
d'autant plus pénalisante que dans le
cadre du c'est dur de la santé les
autres chu ont pris l'initiative de
proposer des plans de financement
complémentaire récemment accepté par les
tutelles malheureusement à marseille du
fait de la situation bloquée aucune
initiative n'a été prise dans ce sens
privant ainsi cette institution d'un
financement complémentaire absolument
nécessaire l'incompréhension locales et
totale face à cette situation et le
ressenti est celui d'un certain mépris
pour les acteurs de terrain ce sentiment
de mépris est exacerbée 12 féminisme par
la rumeur entretenue par la presse selon
laquelle le nouveau directeur de l'ap-hm
pourrait être monsieur salomon actuel
directeur général de la santé décision
prise par paris
sans tenir compte du choix des décideurs
locaux dont renaud muselier qui étaient
tous d'accord sur la personne de
monsieur crémieux madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer qu'un quel est
votre décision quant à la nomination du
nouveau directeur de l'ap-hm merci
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué chargé
l'autonomie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur alain milon
évidemment d'abord cette décision je
vous rassure ne m'appartient pas je l'a
confirmé et d'autre part il ne faut
jamais croire les rumeurs il est normal
que la vacance ayant disputé il ya en
débuté que nous entamions les
consultations nécessaires évidemment à
la nomination à la tête de cet ensemble
aussi prestigieux je peux vous confirmer
que le processus de recrutement a été
lancée vous me l'avez dit aussi les
candidatures ont été examinées par un
comité de sélection locale avec d'une
part la rs et d'autre part le doyen le
président de la commission médicale
d'établissement et la mairie de
marseille
trois noms étaient proposées au
ministère à l'issue de ce processus les
échanges se sont poursuivis notamment
avec les acteurs locaux dans toutes les
procédures
deux éléments importants justifie la
poursuite des discussions compte tenu de
l'importance de ce centre et la
difficulté de l'exercice de diriger une
telle institution
le processus de désignation est capital
il est normal d'en prendre le plus grand
soin vous en conviendrez est par
ailleurs le ministère des solidarités à
veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'intérim
encore plus au regard de la situation
actuelle nous avons donc prolonger le
précédent directeur général pour assurer
la continuité la décision sera prise en
conseil des ministres dans les meilleurs
délais soyez en rassurés
merci monsieur milan 27 secondes oui
merci monsieur le président je me
doutais bien que la réponse ne pouvait
pas venir directement du ministère
puisque il paraîtrait qu'elle soit au
niveau du bureau du président de la
république je vous régis dire juste une
chose monsieur monsieur salomon
dont on connaît les relations ambiguës
avec les agences monsieur véran à dc qui
les tenait beaucoup s'en séparer sans
s'en séparer pour s'en séparer n'est pas
une solution ni pour la ph n de
marseille ni pour monsieur salomon lui
même ce premier point le deuxième point
retarder les décisions entraînent un
retard de financement pour la ph n et
c'est préjudiciable pour l'ensemble d'un
provence
la parole maintenant monsieur hervé
maurey pour le groupe union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations chargé des collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la direction générale
des collectivités locales vient de
publier la répartition de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement pour l'année
2000 21
si son montant est globalement stable
cette année encore plus de la moitié des
communes 53 % exactement connaissent une
diminution de cette dotation
ces diminutions ne concerne qu'un tiers
des communes de plus de 20 mille
habitants mais 55% des communes de moins
de 1000 habitants
ces communes qui ont déjà une dotation
forfaitaire par habitant bien
inférieures à celles des communes
urbaines observe ainsi leur recette déjà
limitée diminué d'année en année ayant
de plus en plus de difficultés à
équilibrer leur budget le fait que les
communes de toutes tailles d'ailleurs
ignore la cause des diminutions temps le
calcul de la dgf et opaque accentue
l'incompréhension des élus concernés
cette situation à la ministre est
particulièrement choquante cette année
alors que du fait de la crise sanitaire
les communes et notamment les communes
rurales ont eu à supporter des dépenses
supplémentaires et à supporter des
baisses de recettes qui n'ont été ni
l'une ni l'autre compenser en totalité
par l'état
j'aurai donc vous demander madame la
ministre pourquoi ces diminutions
pourquoi sont-elles si nombreuses
pourquoi touche-t-elle plus
particulièrement les petites communes et
vous demander s'il n'aurait pas été
opportun compte tenu de la situation
d'accorder à minima un gel sur les
baisses de dotations cette année merci
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault min sur la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur hervé maurey
vous avez rappelé que la stabilité de
l'envelope de dgf était une réalité
je rappelle par ailleurs que la dgf ses
7 % des dépenses du budget de l'état et
15% des recettes des communes en moyenne
c'est donc bien loin d'être
naturellement anodin bien sûr il y à
chaque année des redéploiements au sein
de la dgf alors pas au hasard monsieur
moret mais on tient compte de la
variation de la population des communes
ou encore de la richesse fiscale
les évolutions individuelles et vous le
savez existe toutefois modérée en 2021
80% des variations sont inférieurs à 1%
des recettes de fonctionnement des
budgets maintenant il ya bien sûr la
question du niveau de base de la dgf et
notamment le fameux coefficient
logarithmique je rappelle d'abord que ce
coefficient qui existe depuis près de 20
ans traduit le fait que les charges
d'une commune croise avec une population
cette corrélation n'est contesté par
personne y compris par ceux qui avaient
envisagé une réforme de la dgf
pour prendre un exemple que vous
connaissez bien monsieur le sénateur a
berné par exemple berner soit 250 euros
de dgf par habitant contre 172 euros en
moyenne dans son intercommunalité et
pourquoi il n'ya pas parce que berné est
au coeur d'un bassin de vie et fournit
des services et des équipements à une
population qui dépasse largement son
territoire j'ajoute qu'il faut regarder
la question en dynamique depuis 2010 est
les communes de moins de 3500 habitants
ont gagné 72 millions d'euros de dg
sous le quinquennat précédent elle en
avait perdu 500 millions de dotations je
vous rappelle par ailleurs que nous
avons réformé la dgf des
intercommunalités en 19 en 2019 dans un
sens très favorable aux
intercommunalités rurales souvent
conclus et qui étaient pénalisés
cette année encore 75% des communes des
communautés de communes vraiment au
congo lui hors dotation augmenté je vous
remercie monsieur morts et 23 secondes
oui je suis présent c'est madame amis ce
trophée vous intéressiez dgf de berne et
vous auriez pu aussi parler de celle de
vernon qui est trois fois supérieure à
celle de louviers alors que ce sont des
villes de taille sensiblement comparable
et que la population augmente à louviers
et pas à vernon mais ça n'est pas le
sujet ce que je regrette c'est que vous
n'ayez pas répondu à ma question et que
vous ne répondiez pas aux inquiétudes
des maires des communes rurales qui
voient chaque année baisser leur
dotation sans avoir d'explication
rationnelle et cette situation elle
conduit à des votes protestataires que
vous regrettez mais vous ne faites rien
pour les empêcher par un tel
comportement
[Applaudissements]
c'est
hall est maintenant marie-claude varia
ce pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologistes vous avez la parole
chaque collègue à mme la ministre du
logement
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors que notre pays fait face à une
crise sanitaire mondiale c'est à présent
une crise sociale majeure que nous
devons affronter
à l'heure où de très nombreuses familles
sont confrontées à la précarité des
associations demande de prolongement de
la trêve hivernale jusqu'au 31 octobre
les expulsions locatives des gens aux
constantes depuis des années pour ainsi
doubler cette année si rien n'est fait
selon l'insee parmi les 10% de ménages
les plus modestes 35% ont subi une
dégradation de leur situation financière
la banque de france et voit elle un pic
de chômage supérieur à 11 et demi pour
cent d'ici quelques mois
comme le souligne la confédération
nationale du logement qui a lancé une
pétition à ce sujet il convient de ne
pas ajouter à la situation économique et
psychologique dramatique l'angoissé
d'une expulsion pour des milliers de
ménages
une expulsion locative n'est pas un
simple acte administratif c'est un drame
humain aux multiples répercussions
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutenons l'idée d'une sécurité sociale
du logement via un fonds de solidarité
nationale
madame la ministre que comptez vous
faire pour garantir le droit au logement
reconnu comme un objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle
allez vous enfin reporter la taille
hivernale comme nous le demandons
systématiquement et comme l'autorisent
le projet de loi permettant la sortie de
l'état d'urgence dans son article 7
mais surtout allez vous faire de l'année
2021 une année zéro expulsions locatives
merci
répandre la parole est à madame
emmanuelle wargon ministre délégué
chargé du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice marie claude varaillas face à
la crise sanitaire que nous connaissons
nous avons pris des mesures
exceptionnelles pour protéger les
locataires vulnérable dès l'année
dernière à l'issue de la trêve hivernale
que nous avons prolongé jusqu'à juillet
2020 nous avons fixé comme consigne
qu'il n'y ait pas d'expulsion sans
proposition de relogement ou
d'hébergement consignes qui s'est
traduite par un nombre d'expulsions
exceptionnellement bas en 2020 nous
prolongeons à nouveau la trêve hivernale
cette année du 31 mars au 31 mai et nous
avons par ailleurs ouvert un nombre
exceptionnel de places d'hébergement
pour la mise à l'abri nous en sommes
aujourd'hui à plus de 200 milles c'est
un geste de solidarité très fort
vis-à-vis des personnes en difficulté
nous devons désormais réussir la fin de
la trêve la fin de ces mesures
temporaires pour assurer un retour
progressif au cadre de la loi
nous préparons donc depuis plusieurs
mois avec toutes les associations de
solidarité la fin de cette trêve avec
une priorité continuer à protéger les
personnes précaires et vulnérable si une
expulsion a lieu après le 1er juin elle
sera assortie d'une proposition de
relogement ou à minima d'hébergement un
travail sera fait également en amont de
l'expulsion pour proposer un
accompagnement social et une solution
aux locataires cette transition face au
droit commun nous devons la réussir car
nous devons aussi prendre en compte la
situation des petits propriétaires dont
le loyer constitue une source importante
de revenus et nous ne pouvons pas avoir
une année blanche en matière
d'expulsions c'est aussi pour cette
raison que l'état s'est engagé à
indemniser rapidement les propriétaires
concernés et nous abonderons dès juillet
le fonds d'indemnisation des
propriétaires bailleurs d'un montant
complémentaire estimé à 20 millions
d'euros
enfin nous avons décidé de mettre en
place à titre exceptionnel pour 2021 30
millions d'euros de fonds des doses
impayés de loyer une
mende porté par les associations qui
abonderont les fonds solidarité logement
des collectivités locales pour aider les
ménages en situation de difficulté à se
maintenir dans leur logement si madame
madame la ministre je note que votre
réponse est loin de me satisfaire
il faut sortir le logement de la logique
marchande
nous avons besoin de moyens financiers
non seulement pour le fonds
d'indemnisation mais aussi pour les
bailleurs afin de construire du logement
social et pour la réquisition des
logements vacants ce ne sommes pas vos
vague d'instruction préfet niveau
annonce qui changeront la donne et
permettez moi de vous dire de vous
rappeler madame la ministre que les
solutions d'hébergement ne seront jamais
qui valente un accès pérenne au logement
merci la parole est maintenant madame
l'a déjà fait pour le groupe pour
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes indépendant ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale mes premiers mots
vont aux équipes pédagogiques et aux
élèves qui ont repris partout en france
le chemin de l'école lundi dernier dans
une année difficile très difficile il
faut saluer des efforts remarquables de
leur part et aussi des inquiétudes
légitimes qui sont aujourd'hui exprimer
al'approche des examens finaux et qu'il
nous faut entendre nos terminal
notamment aborde la dernière ligne
droite avant ce rite de passage que
représente le baccalauréat est un
diplôme cadre qui est aussi une entrée
dans l'enseignement supérieur et dans
l'âge adulte une porte d'entrée vers les
diplômes vers les études supérieures des
diplômes des épreuves le stress qui va
avec un stress accru dans la période
actuelle les épreuves le grand oral est
la philosophie arrive
certains expriment des doutes quant à la
faisabilité pour les lycéennes et les
lycéens de plancher en présentiel des
inégalités dans l'avancement des
programmes en fonction des
établissements sont mis en avant
nous le savons le virus a frappé partout
mais il n'a pas touché les territoires
et les lycées de la même façon ni avec
la même intensité et les mêmes
conséquences en matière de continuité
écologique même si la france a connu un
maintien du nombre de jours d'école
remarquable par rapport aux autres pays
depuis le
la pandémie face à ces constats monsieur
le ministre il faut prévoir
faut-il prévoir un contrôle continu
généralisée faut-il prévoir des
aménagements supplémentaires
certains ont déjà été opérées je pense
aux épreuves de spécialités de mars aux
épreuves anticipées de français de
classe de première es au contrôle
continu de l'épreuve de philosophie et
aux contenus parlons de l'épreuve de
philosophie
vous avez rencontré hier les syndicats
et organisations lycéennes afin
d'étudier de nouvelles pistes pour à
jouer ajustez les épreuves pour dié vous
nous en dire plus et notamment pour la
spécificité des élèves inscrits dans les
écoles hors contrat je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
mama sénatrice nadège av c'est
évidemment une question très importante
et beaucoup de jeunes se les posent ces
questions ainsi que leurs familles et le
mot clé c'est celui de bienveillance
depuis évidemment le début de cette
crise sanitaire le autres l'autre mot
clé c'est celui de pragmatisme nous
devons nous adapter aux circonstances
merci d'avoir souligné le fait que nous
avons réussi quelque chose que les
autres pays européens n'ont pas fait
c'est à dire maintenir les
établissements ouverts mais bien entendu
l'année n'a quand même pas été normale
et vous l'avez noté il ya de
l'hétérogénéité en particulier
éventuellement entre entre les lycéens
c'est pourquoi nous procédons à des
adaptations
nous l'avons déjà fait tout au long de
l'année vous savez nous avons un comité
de suivi du baccalauréat nous avons
aussi un comité de suivi spécifiques de
la voie professionnelle
que ce soit pour le baccalauréat général
et technologique ou pour le baccalauréat
professionnel
nous nous adaptons vous avez noté les
plus importantes de ces adaptations
récentes notamment le fait d'avoir
transformé en contrôle continu
les épreuves terminales qui était prévu
en mars et puis il reste devant nous
pour le baccalauréat général et
technologique
l'épreuve de philosophie écrite et le
grand oral comme vous l'avez dit j'ai
reçus y
les visioconférences les organisations
lycéennes nous discutons aussi
aujourd'hui avec les organisations
représentatives des personnels
bien entendu il ya des propositions qui
parfois peuvent être contradictoires
entre elles notre objectif c'est aussi
de maintenir la valeur du diplôme notre
objectif c'est évidemment d'amener les
élèves vers la réussite
c'est le seul et unique objectif est de
le faire dans des conditions qui leur
soient bonnes et donc nous voulons qu'il
se passe une épreuve terminal le plus
possible mais en même temps nous
cherchons des aménagements pour que tout
simplement ils puissent réussir
c'est pourquoi il y aura par exemple
très vraisemblablement des mesures pour
que un élève lorsqu'il arrive à un oral
puisse indiquer les parties du programme
qui n'ont pas été vues signé le document
étant signée par son professeur c'est un
exemple parmi les aménagements que nous
allons pouvoir donner
nous continuons à discuter donc je ne
peux évidemment pas vous donner
maintenant la suite d'autant plus que
c'est un petit peu complexe parce qu'il
ya aussi le baccalauréat professionnel
avec ses spécificités
les épreuves de français de première je
ne doute pas que nous allons arriver à
cette solution pragmatique et
bienveillante qui sont donc les deux
mots clés et c'est au cours des
prochaines heures ou les prochains jours
que je pourrais donner la solution à
laquelle nous arrivons je vous remercie
merci merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur franck
montaugé pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre que je salue les politiques
dures pour les faibles et faible pour
l'effort votre réforme de l'assurance
chômage comme un marqueur politique de
plus illustres que vous n'avez pas le
souci des situations de vie
problématique au quotidien que subissent
trop beaucoup trop de nos concitoyens
le chômage ce n'est pas un concept
théorique c'est une réalité humaine
dévastatrices que je connais
personnellement dans la chair de ma
chair un cancer sociétal qui plongeait
des femmes et des hommes responsables
désireux de travailler attaché quoi
qu'en dise et ont tellement certains à
leur contribution économique à la
société française en même temps qu'à
leur autonomie de vie je crois que vous
ne savez pas ce qu'est
moralement de se retrouver à la proche
de la fin des droits quand on a de
jeunes des enfants est souvent une
maison une maison qu'il va falloir
vendre parce que le projet de vie vole
en éclats à cause de la perte des droits
moi comme des millions de français je le
sais est votre politique n'en apparaît
que plus injuste violente a fortiori
dans cette période où les problèmes
sociaux et sociétaux sont hélas déjà là
est appelé à croître faire payer aux
plus faibles d'entre nous près de 1
milliard et demi d'euros au moment où à
bon droit
on y note de l'économie de centaines de
milliards d'euros il fallait oser
vous l'avez fait ma question est simple
comment envisagez vous de sortir de ce
dossier al'avantage des chômeurs qui ne
demande qu'à retrouver au plus vite un
travail utile censé hauteur de leur
qualification est au bénéfice de notre
société
merci vous répondre la parole est à
madame brigitte klinkert ministre
délégué chargé de l'insertion
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur franck montaugé la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est l'aboutissement
de six mois de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux et et vous le savez
aussi nous aussi sommes proches des
territoires et proche des habitants de
nos concitoyens cette réforme née d'un
constat c'est que le système actuel est
injuste et ans demandeurs d'emploi qui
travaille à mi-temps perçoit une
allocation très inférieurs un demandeur
qui travaillent une semaine sur deux
pour le même salaire et le même nombre
d'heures travaillées
cela n'est pas satisfaisant et ce
système est coûteux
l'alternance entre contrats courts et
périodes de chômages coût de près de 3
milliards d'euros par an à l'assurance
chômage
et puis plus globalement le système le
régime est déficitaire depuis plus de
dix ans avec près de 40 milliards de
dettes cumulées
avant même la crise de l'aco vide le
système actuel a enfermé de nombreux
demandeurs d'emploi dans le chômage et
il a encouragé la précarité
j'en veux pour preuve un chiffre le
nombre de cdd de moins d'un an
mois a augmenté de 250% en disant avec
le bonus malus les entreprises seront
désormais incitée à proposer davantage
de cdi et à rallonger la durée des cdd
face à la crise nous avons adapté
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
d'abord nous avons prolonger les
allocations des demandeurs d'emploi en
fin de droits pour près de sept cent
mille personnes depuis fin octobre
dernier pour 2,5 milliards d'euros au
total
ensuite nous avons décalé la réforme au
1er juillet et son déploiement sera
progressif
je veux rassurer nos concitoyens notre
système d'assurance chômage restera très
protecteur puisque nous maintenons une
durée longue d'indemnisation un taux de
remplacement relativement élevée et des
conditions d'affiliation très ouverte
enfin le montant global d'indemnisation
du demandeur d'emploi restera le même
c'est la durée qui est prolongé par la
réforme je vous remercie
merci monsieur montaugé mais merci
madame même si le premier ministre
le quoi qu'il en coûte 7 uniquement
cyniquement transformer en quoi qu'il en
coûte socialement quant à nous nous
rejetons et nous combattrons avec
fermeté et sens de la justice
cette politique de décors 2d cohésion
sociale et les autres que vous dites
vouloir mener en vert et contre tous
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
christian bilhac pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président madame navi
sera culture mes chers collègues durant
la période estivale nos communes vivent
au rythme des fêtes locales et des bals
populaires toute particulière les
romains daleux chute de l'offre off
cette tradition a été interrompue l'été
dernier en raison de la crise sanitaire
et cette année tous les acteurs
s'interrogent sur sa possibilité de
retrouver ces moments forts de
convivialité
les musiciens qui souhaitent ont
retrouvé leur pupitre après une année
noire
les organisateurs qu'il s'agisse des
communes ou des associations ne
connaissent pas encore
jour les protocoles sanitaires et les
gens là qu'ils vont devoir respecter les
fêtes estivales de plein air sont
traditionnellement gratuite et le plus
souvent organisée par des comités des
fêtes ou des associations de proximité
et il met en cache des buvettes qui sont
une source de revenus non négligeable
lors de ces rassemblements de population
aussi mal a remis ça quelques semaines
de les tirs et dans la perspective du
prochain déconfinement annoncé les
musiciens notamment qu'une chose pouvoir
jouer se produire à nouveau de ce fait
de local car il n'y a pas que les grands
festivals pour animer notre victoire
je n'oublierai pas non plus la situation
des foraine qui attendent avec
impatience de pouvoir installer leurs
manèges ou autres l'attraction de la
ministre en 2020 les normes sanitaires
avaient entraîné de facto
l'impossibilité d'organiser de tels
événements
pouvez vous indiquer si pour l'été qui
arrive les fêtes locales et autres
manifestations populaires de plein air
pourront reprendre sans que des
protocoles sanitaires
excessifs ne fasse peser une
responsabilité insoutenable sur les
épaules et organisateurs en effet il
semblerait que les manifestations
extérieures n'engendre pas trop la
propagation du virus
merci la parole est à madame roselyne
bachelot ministre de la culture
il a plus rien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur christian bilhac
vous avez souligné l'importance aux
côtés des manifestations culturelles
classique de ces fêtes de village de ces
manifestations souvent gratuites et qui
contribue à l'animation des territoires
et en particulier des territoires ruraux
bien entendu nous continuerons à aider
toutes ces manifestations à travers un
certain nombre de mécanismes de soutien
dont il bénéficie d'ores et déjà aussi à
travers des mécanismes comme le statut
de l'intermittence
c'est évidemment extrêmement important
nous avons fixé un certain nombre de
cadres dans ceux des confinement et bien
entendu les fêtes de village
bénéficieront je les appelle comme ça
parce qu'on se fait ça ça recouvre des
manifestations très différente
bénéficieront des mesures et devront à
s'adapter aux mesures qui ont été
définies a annoncé par le président de
la république dans le calendrier des
jauges et des précautions sanitaires
vous évoquez par exemple une question
très précise la question de la
restauration des bars qui accompagnent
ces manifestations et qui sont
évidemment très importante pour assurer
leur pérennité économique
finalement ceux qui s'adaptent au
restaurant-bar devront s'adapter à la
restauration et au système de barre qui
accompagne en particulier à travers les
buvettes les manifestations il n'y a pas
de raison de déroger à ces mesures de
protection sanitaire
c'est extrêmement important par contre
je veux être très clair et et précise si
nous avons un calendrier de
d'élargissement des jauges des plafonds
du couvre feu avec des mesures qui sont
pratiquement tout lever au 1er juillet
il n'est pas question parce que le virus
continue de circuler et de circuler de
façon forte
il n'est pas question de lever les
précautions sanitaires qui sont destinés
à nous protéger et à protéger nos
concitoyens y compris dans les fêtes de
village
il faut se sont pas des mesures
barrières parce que ne nous éloigne pas
les uns des autres ce sont des mesures
de protection porter un masque se laver
les mains
respectez les distances iations social
ces du respect c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
que nous arriverons à mener une vie
normale
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur thomas d'hossus pour le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire oui le
madame la ministre
le 25 mars les portes du conseil
régional d'occitanie ont été forcés par
des militants de l'action française aux
cris de mort aux islamo-gauchiste
reprenant le vocabulaire en vogue au
gouvernement le 17 avril un ancien ami
du président de la république philippe
de villiers appelait dans valeurs
actuelles à l'insurrection pour selon
lui évité la disparition de la france le
21 avril dernier des généraux ont publié
une tribune factieuses menaçant le pays
de guerre civile pour lutter contre
l'indigénisme et les ordres de banlieue
et n'entraînant que des réactions
tardives et timorée de votre
gouvernement
c'est à ces actes et propos ne sont pas
isolés par tous la parole se libère et
l'extrême droite la plus radicale passe
aux actes
cette extrême droite est une menace
grandissante est mortel pour notre
république
face à ce danger les digues ont sauté
avec la république en mars qui parfois
la trouve trop molle mais aussi avec une
partie la droite républicaine de cet
hémicycle
j'en veux pour preuve la liste est
interminable d'amendements stigmatisant
qui ont été adoptées ici par le sénat
sur le projet de loi séparatisme à
l'encontre de nos concitoyens musulmans
ou encore les attaques frontales et
scandaleuse de satin de vos collègues
ministres parlementaires à l'encontre du
monde universitaire qualifié d'
islamo-gauchiste ces discours ne sont
pas sans conséquences
jusque dans nos territoires notamment à
lyon le 3 mars le gouvernement a annoncé
la dissolution de la génération y coller
un peu de calme le son était nécessaire
et bienvenue sur mouvement est très
implantée à lyon
or depuis cette dissolution à lyon le 19
mars une quarantaine d'hommes lance des
pavés et saccagent amitié une librairie
le 24 avril une quarantaine d'individus
d'extrême droite ont lancé des
projectiles sur une manifestation le 1er
mai le local d'une radio lyonnaise a été
attaqué par l'extrême droite
ces bandes violentes agissant au vu et
au su de tous sans être inquiété et pour
cause l'époque leur est favorable
leurs paroles a été légitimé et par
conséquent leur violence est libérée
dans la foulée
ainsi l'outil la dissolution ne suffit
pas tout le monde peut le constater mada
la ministe ma question est simple
à quel moment votre gouvernement va-t-il
arrêter d'être complaisant avec
l'extrême droite et lutter réellement
contre sa montée avec une détermination
à la hauteur de la menace qu'elle fait
peser sur la république merci
merci allez allez on se calme on se
calme pas des buts allaient la parole
est à madame geneviève darrieussecq
ministre déléguée chargée de la mémoire
et des anciens combattants
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je n'ai pas saisi toute la question
parce que le bruit ambiant le bruit
ambiant m'a empêché d'entendre
l'intégralité de l'intervention et de la
question je vous répondrais sur deux
thèmes le premier dont vous avez parlé
monsieur le sénateur il s'agit de la
tribune des généraux où vous nous dites
que vous dites que notre gouvernement
est inactif
je veux rappeler une chose monsieur le
sénateur c'est que les armées ne
représente pas un parti politique quel
qu'il soit malgré ce que certains élus
ont l'air d'en penser qu'un militaire
n'est pas un militant et que les armées
sont là pour protéger les français tous
les français
et quiconque aurait un avis différent
des zones regrets nos armées et notre
république et que florence parly a eu
l'occasion de l'indiquer les cinquante
deux officiers généraux qui ne sont plus
en activité seront traduit devant un
conseil supérieur d'armé en vue de leur
radiation et que les dix-huit militaires
d'activé d'ian violé le devoir de
réserve serait soumis à des sanctions
disciplinaires
sous la responsabilité du chef d'état
major des armées
deuxième chose monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur je crois que le
ministère de l'intérieur travaillent
activement aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur engagé la procédure de
dissolution de génération identitaire le
conseil d'état a estimé que cette
association était bien responsable de
provocation à la haine et à la
discrimination
je crois donc que vous ne pouvez pas
dire monsieur le sénateur que nous
n'agissons pas que nous ne sommes pas
vigilants et que toutes les les
manifestations les paroles qui amène une
fracture et une violence dans notre pays
et notamment une violence d'extrême
droite sont combattus au plus haut
niveau
merci la parole est maintenant madame
sabine drexler pour le groupe est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur le
ministre
un tiers des communes vont devoir
augmenter leur taxe foncière en 2021
c'est ce que relève un sondage réalisé
par la mf cette hausse de la fiscalité
est la conséquence des baisses de
dotations et de recettes que les
collectivités locales subissent depuis
le début du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron et qui ne sont jamais
intégralement compensée c'est aussi la
résultante de l'accumulation des
dépenses exceptionnelles auxquelles les
collectivités locales font face depuis
18 mois pour répondre aux besoins de
leurs populations des acteurs
économiques et du monde associatif
la dernière en date étant la mise en
place de plus de 1400 centres de
vaccination par les communes qu'elles
financent pour l'instant intégralement
sans avoir aucune visibilité sur la
participation de l'état
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous vous engagez devant notre
assemblée aujourd'hui à ce que l'état
compense intégralement les coûts engagés
par les collectivités locales pour la
mise en place de ces centres de
vaccination ou un mini map
vous vous engagez à permettre aux
communes de pouvoir bénéficier du
système d'indemnisation appliquée aux
structures de soin et aux professionnels
de santé
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie oui madame
la sénatrice sabine drexler contenu de
la de pardon je ne vous avais pas fait
vous m'interrogez sur la prise en charge
de l'effort budgétaire des collectivités
oui je vous vois bien dans la mise en
place des centres de vaccination qui je
le rappelle ont été demandées par les
collectivités bien sûr et nous avons
bien sûr procédé a alors demandé à cette
affectation le fonds d'intervention
régional des ars doit être mobilisée et
peut-être mobilisé bien sûr pour
participer aux dépenses de
fonctionnement des centres de
vaccination dans une logique de
partenariat entre état et collectivités
des conventions de subvention sont à cet
effet signé entre les ars et les
structures portant les centres de
vaccination et qui vise à financer les
surcoûts auxquelles les collectivités
qui y portent des centres sont exposés
donc vous voyez la réponse est claire
nous avons délégué dès le 18 février 60
millions d'euros aux agences régionales
de santé
source firent pour financer les dépenses
les plus urgentes des 1200 centres
ouverts sur le territoire et ses
subventions peuvent comprendre la prise
en charge de moyens de fonctionnement
tels que le secrétariat la coordination
l'accueil la mobilisation des agents
pour le fonctionnement des centres le
week end et en plus de leur temps de
travail habituel et qui peut être
considéré aussi comme un surcoût est
donné lieu à un financement
le recrutement des personnes
complémentaires peut également donner
lieu à un financement les personnels
prescripteurs effecteur indemnisés par
la sécurité sociale
la participation des sapeurs pompiers
peuvent également être prises en charge
dans certaines conditions vous le voyez
nous avons donc pallier ces
insuffisances que vous signalez mais
pour autant elles sont déjà prévus
déjà financé il faut donc que vous
rapprocher de votre adresse merci madame
marie claire madame la ministre a les
communes se sont fortement investis en
cette période inédite ils ont une
nouvelle fois montré leur réactivité et
leur application
mais les dotations forfaitaires promise
par le gouvernement sont largement
insuffisantes
la situation financière des
collectivités locales se dégrade plus
vite que vous ne le pensez les budgets
qu'ovide pèsent extrêmement lourd
les collectivités ne vont pas pouvoir
continuer à faire toujours plus de
dépenses avec toujours moins de rentrées
d'argent
notre gouvernement a fait des promesses
pour que les prises en charge soit bien
supérieur
les élus locaux attendent que vous les
respectez merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
luc fichet pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le monde de
traverse la plus grande crise sanitaire
de la période moderne
si nous disposons aujourd'hui de vaccins
contre le coc vite 19 faisons face à une
vague plus violente encore que les
précédentes
nous devons accélérer le rythme de
vaccination partout à l'échelle de la
planète y compris en france
nous ne sommes toutefois pas convaincu
que la stratégie européenne et mondiale
se donne tous les moyens d'y parvenir
plus de 100 gouvernements nationaux dont
l'inde et l'afrique du sud avec le
directeur général de l' oms et de
nombreux experts de santé plaide pour
une dérogation temporaire aux règles de
propriété intellectuelle afin de
permettre une couverture vaccinale la
plus large possible
alors que cette demande est aujourd'hui
discutée à l'om un mc parlons
l'opposition de l'union européenne et de
la france à cette levée temporaire est
incompréhensible selon deux économistes
la plupart des habitants des pays
africains ne seront pas vaccinés avant
il faudra attendre 2022
pour de nombreux pays émergents combien
de nouveaux variants d'ici là combien de
morts supplémentaires combien d'économie
à terre monsieur le premier ministre
les vaccins contre le coc vide 19
doivent devenir un bien commun de
l'humanité
ma question est simple la france
va-t-elle porter la levée temporaire des
règles de propriété intellectuelle pour
ces vaccins en europe et dans le monde
je vous remercie merci à vous répandre
la parole est à monsieur cédric au
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
transition numérique et des
communications électroniques
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean luc fichet il ya un point
sur lequel nous nous rejoignons
complètement je crois monsieur le
sénateur c'est la nécessité de vacciner
le plus vite possible le plus de monde
possible à l'échelle de la planète pour
des raisons de solidarité des raisons
humanitaires que l'on comprend
évidemment pour des raisons d'efficacité
puisque ce que l'on apprend de la crise
des variants c'est que même si l'europe
devait être complètement vaccinés
si le virus continue à évoluer et à
produire des variants ailleurs dans le
monde nous ré importe riom
systématiquement ces variants et donc
nous avons besoin de faire en sorte que
tout le monde soit vaccinée c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que la france a pris la
tête d'un certain nombre de pays
développés qui sont des gros acheteurs
de vaccins pour faire en sorte de
données et fournir aux pays du sud
notamment des doses de vaccin
je pense aux centaines de milliers de
doses qui ont été donnés unilatéralement
par la france dans le cadre de
l'initiative
kovacs je pense à l'engagement du
président de la république qui je crois
est assez unique dans les pays
développés de donner 5 % des doses
française à destination des pays du sud
est ce que une levée des brevets de
manière temporaire serait de nature à
répondre aux défis que vous évoquez je
ne suis pas sûr il est même possible que
ce soit une fausse bonne idée pour la
raison suivante d'abord le premier
problème n'est pas un problème de brevet
même si tous les brevets étaient en
accès libre
il faudrait il n'y aurait pas de
production supplémentaire pour les pays
du sud avant
2022 compte tenu de la complexité
industrielle que cela représente
il faut 18 mois pour valider une usine
deuxièmement nous avons nécessité de
faire en sorte que les industriels
continuent à investir dans la recherche
pour développer les réponses aux
nouveaux variants si nous leur retire
ont la propriété intellectuelle il y à
des risques qu ils soient d en citer
deux d'investir dans la recherche sur
les nouveaux variants enfin mais c'est
moins valides pour une autorisation
temporaire autant il faut donner des
doses autant transférés de manière
unilatérale est longue
un brevet et la recherche qui va avec
c'est prendre des risques il faut en
avoir conscience en matière de
délocalisation et donc il n'est autant
le sujet doit être étudié il faut
transférer aloses mais la question je me
sens libre est un féculent infiniment
plus compliqué je vous remercie
tu es une poignée de secondes monsieur
fichiers oui monsieur le monsieur le
ministre vous imaginez bien combien ce
n'est pas satisfaisant comme type de
réponse puisque vous nous apporter les
solutions avant même qu'on ait évoqué
l'hypothèse de mettre les vaccins dans
ce domaine public
cependant il faut quand même savoir que
la recherche est financée dans sa très
grande majeure partie par l'état et donc
par l'argent public et donc ça
nécessiterait effectivement campus
avancer très vite sur ce sujet d'al bien
évidemment je parle du coc vide
merci la parole est à madame jacky
d'euromédis pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
chaque mois le groupe américain
bloomberg classe la résilience des
cinquante trois économies les plus
importantes
singapour est en tête de ce classement
très loin derrière la france se situe en
42e position 16 pays européens sont
mieux classés que nous la france a perdu
18 places par rapport au mois précédent
cela s'expliquerait par l'arrivée des
variants et l'échec des mesures de
freinage la campagne vaccinale de 2009
pour la grippe h1n1 avait eu le mérite
de ne laisser aucun de nos compatriotes
résidant à l'étranger sur le bord du
chemin
ce n'est malheureusement pas le cas
aujourd'hui on ne saurait remettre en
cause le sérieux des 10 critères de ce
classement qui prennent non seulement en
compte des indicateurs de la propagation
de l'aco vide mais aussi la qualité de
vie
ces critères sont notamment le nombre de
cas et le taux de mortalité au cours du
dernier mois le nombre de décès depuis
le début de la pandémie la part de la
population couverte par les vaccins
pour ce qui est de la qualité de vie
sont noté la sévérité du confinement
la variation du produit intérieur brut
la couverture universelle des soins de
santé et l' indice de développement
humain
à titre d'exemple avec 1609 mort pour
cent mille personnes
la france est le troisième plus mauvais
élève dans le classement bloomberg
nul ne mettra en doute des sources qui
sont pour n'en citer que trois
l'université d'oxford
le fonds monétaire international et
google monsieur le premier ministre le
gouvernement semblent satisfaits de son
action
alors que manifestement les résultats ne
sont pas au rendez vous comment
expliquez vous une telle contre
performance
merci répondre la parole est à madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice jacky de
memory d'euromédis
comme vous madame nous avons le souci de
l'efficience de l'action publique
c'est pourquoi je nous nous attachons à
ce que peuvent dire certains classements
dont la méthodologie les critères sont
pertinents que dit le classement
bloomberg madame la sénatrice il dit la
france s'est maintenue dans les 20 pays
qui agissent le mieux face au virus
il dit qu au 25 avril et c'est vrai
madame la sénatrice la situation était
difficile mais la dernière mesure
coïncide avec le pic de la dernière
vague épidémique est cyniquement je vous
dirais que vous oubliez au passage les
chiffres glaçant que nous avons d'autres
pays en termes de nombre de décès les
usa consid toujours 5 178 milles la
grande-bretagne 128000 la france 105000
la situation était difficile
elle a appelé des réponses drastiques
mais nécessaires de renforcement des
mesures de freinage la situation
s'améliore peut-on le dire plus aucun
département ne se trouve au dessus du
seuil de 400 pour cent mille personnes
au taux d'incidence ce même classement
dit aussi que la france est un pays où
les habitants ont un bon accès à la
vaccination
les résultats sont là ce sont des faits
madame la sénatrice près de 16 millions
et demi de français sont vaccinés
c'est près d'un tiers des majeurs de
notre pays plus de 7 millions déjà reçu
la deuxième dose et ce sera le cas d'ici
ce soir
cela se fait grâce à la mobilisation
exceptionnelle que vous nous devrions
collectivement saluer de nos soignants
et parce que nos concitoyens respectent
les mesures sanitaires que nous avons dû
prendre la situation est en train de
s'améliorer et je pense qu'il serait de
bon ton de la saluer merci madame
d'euromédis
madame la ministre je ne suis pas
surprise votre réponse vous avez une
belle marche de prunevelle marge de
progression ce classement n'est pas un
cas isolé puisque l' indice de
performance qu'au vite développée par
l'institut lowy de sydney nous placent
71e sur ce vote sur 102 pays au mois de
mars ce qui n'est guère mieux pour
l'instant quand je me regarde je veux
console quand je me compare je me désole
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean françois longeot pour le groupe
union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé pour laquelle je
tiens à associer ma collègue indique
jacques mais sénatrice du doubs dans
notre pays les ehpad ont payé un lourd
tribut face à la pandémie de kobe 19 le
dernier rapport de la défenseure des
droits pointe d'ailleurs la mise à mal
des droits et libertés de leurs
résidences sur l'urgence de la crise
sanitaire ayant conduit à mettre les
ehpad sous cloche c'est pourquoi la mise
en oeuvre prioritaire de la vaccination
bénéfice des personnes âgées en ehpad
dès le mois de janvier avait suscité
légitimement beaucoup d'espoir le
président de la république dans son
allocution du 31 mars dernier se
félicitait d'ailleurs que les résidents
des maisons de retraite vacciner à plus
de 90%
et puis progressivement reprendre une
vie normale pourtant dans la réalité de
nombreux ehpad
rien n'a changé les contraintes
appliquées aux résidents restent
pratiquement les mêmes confinement
isolement obligatoire en chambre pour
une semaine après tout sorti à
l'extérieur maintien d'une seule visite
par famille et par semaine et qu'une
durée limitée à 30 minutes
pourquoi cet excès de précaution cette
situation vous en conviendrez devient
kafkaïenne on punit les personnes
vaccinées qui risquent alors de mourir
dans la solitude ans les choix de telles
restrictions attentatoires de la liberté
d'aller et de venir ne peut être laissée
à la seule appréciation des directions
des pannes
selon la défense sur des droits monsieur
le ministre
comment rompre avec la protection accrue
dans quelles mesures comptez-vous
prendre en compte au delà des seuls
risques viraux les risques psychosociaux
et affective qui pèse dangereusement sur
nos aînés en ehpad
monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous mettre un terme à l'
isolement sans fin dans les eple je vous
remercie
merci la parole et mettra madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie merci monsieur le
président jean françois longeot la crise
sanitaire vous le savez dans un premier
temps à générer des situations que nul
n'aurait imaginé il y à peu le virus on
le sait désormais et particulièrement
agressif et a été particulièrement
agressif pour nos aînés et qui cela a
demandé évidemment dans un premier temps
des réponses fortes des réponses sous
l'autorité bien sûr des directeurs
d'établissements dont je salue l'esprit
de responsabilité car personne n'est
jamais prêt à faire face à une crise
comme celle ci qui nous a plongé dans
l'inconnu
dès ma nomination cet été j'ai tenu à
les écouter
mais à écouter également les familles
les résidents les conseils de vie que
nous avons vraiment consulter pour les
orienter aussi vers un cap clair
consistant à tirer les enseignements de
cette première vague et concilier deux
principes clés la liberté et la
protection protéger sent isolé c'est ce
qui a été fait dès cet été
pour cela il fallait s'assurer qu'ils
disposent de tous les outils pour
prévenir des clusters pour qu'ils
puissent bénéficier bien sûr en priorité
de la vaccination
je crois qu'on peut reconnaître
collectivement que ce choix a été payant
la campagne de vaccination en ehpad est
un succès avec l'immense majorité des
résidents aujourd'hui protégé c'est
pourquoi j'ai souhaité dès le 12 mars en
lien avec le secteur
un protocole allégé qui est
progressivement mis en oeuvre dans les
établissements
très concrètement un résident en
bénéficiant d'une couverture vaccinale
complète c'est-à-dire qui a eu ses deux
doses sous l'immense majorité doit que
l'immense majorité pardon des résidents
n'a pas à être isolé en rentrant après
une sortie en famille
néanmoins vous avez raison de le
rappeler je reste vigilante car beaucoup
de situations me remonte aujourd'hui et
ce n'est pas tolérable sur la mise en
oeuvre concrète de ce protocole dont je
rappelle les principes essentiels et
vous m'avez permis de le faire
merci monsieur le président dans les
prochains jours nous aurons à nouveau
l'occasion de franchir une nouvelle
étape dans ce chemin des retrouvailles
attendues avec un nouveau ou de
nouvelles recommandations je n'ose plus
dire protocole j'ai beaucoup de cas
résiduels de blocage ou de situations
abusives me sont remontés nous les
observeront et je souhaite en tout cas
dans la majeure partie du temps qu'elle
se résolvent par le dialogue avec les
conseils de vie sociale est née
fenninger et plus fortement toutes les
formes de médiation que nous pourrons y
trouver j'y serai très attentif
merci une poignée de secondes président
l'enjeu non merci
la parole est à madame toile bois pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci mais c'est le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre devant le drame de rambouillet
qui me touche particulièrement et qui
résonne comme un nouvel appel à tuer du
flic devant les policiers visés par des
tirs de mortiers souvent victimes de
guet-apens les émeutes à valence limoges
roman villefranchois encore tourcoing
nos forces de l'ordre incrédule tiennent
le front devant une nouvelle école
incendié à lille et des pompiers attaqué
lors de leur intervention devant des
élus sauvagement agressé encore
dernièrement le maire de poissy pris
pour cible nos forces de l'ordre
incrédule tiennent le front devant les
black blocks qui s'infiltrent dans les
cortèges des manifestations pour
piétiner la démocratie sociale devant
des voyous arrêté qui ricanent sachant
qu'ils seront relâchés le jour même
nos forces de l'ordre incrédule sienne
le ferons quand les obligations de
quitter le territoire ne sont pas
exécutées que vous rétorquer que
l'immigration n'a rien à voir avec la
politique de sécurité
nos forces de l'ordre incrédule tiennent
le ferons quand ils aspirent à plus de
reconnaissance vous créer une plate
forme de signalement des discriminations
qui stigmatise le travail de nos
policiers nos forces de l'ordre
incrédule
sienne le front les forces de l'ordre et
expriment aujourd'hui leur fatigue
devant le renoncement de l'état une
nation qui ne soutient pas ceux qui se
battent pour elle courra la bim
ma question est donc simple que comptez
vous faire pour restaurer l'autorité de
l'état est ainsi réhabiliter nos forces
de l'ordre la parole est à madame
marlène schiappa ministre délégué chargé
de la citoyenneté jeunesse le président
madame la sénatrice thuan bora d'abord
comme l'a fait monsieur pro ministre
lors de la cérémonie à rambouillet et
comme l'a fait a précédemment monsieur
le président du sénat je veux évidemment
rendre hommage ici devant vous à
stéphanie cette policière qui a été
sauvagement assassinés dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions alors qu'elle servait
son pays au commissariat de rambouillet
depuis 28 ans était un des visages de
notre police envisage de celles et ceux
qui au quotidien protège et vous avez
raison le rappeler ligne de notre devoir
de protéger ceux qui protègent et avec
gérald a maintenant au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le sens de l'action
que nous menons avec les forces de
l'ordre
c'est pour cela que nous avons souhaité
ici même faire voter un budget en
augmentation historique pour la sécurité
et je vous remercie d'ailleurs de
l'avoir votée en constatant que ce
budget était en augmentation forte et en
augmentation historique c'est aussi pour
cela qu'avec le ministre de l'intérieur
nous voulons mieux doter les policiers
parce que respecter les policiers
respecter les gendarmes c'est aussi
respecter leur travail et c'est leur
permettre d'avoir le matériel nécessaire
qu'il s'agisse de tenus qu'il s'agissent
de vidéoprotection et c'est l'engagement
du ministre de l'intérieur lors de tous
ses déplacements auprès des élus et vous
le savez comme gérald darmanin l'a
rappelé d'ailleurs avec gravité malgré
le travail exceptionnel des services de
renseignement français qui ont déjoué 35
attentats depuis janvier 2017 et que je
veux ici saluer malgré le recrutement
dès 1900 policiers supplémentaires dans
les services de renseignement malgré le
doublement du budget de la dgs
malgré les textes anti terroristes qui
sont votées quinquennat après
quinquennat et bien malgré cela oui
notre pays est toujours la cible à la
fois du terrorisme islamiste mais aussi
de menaces et de violence forte est il
admissible contre les forces de l'ordre
j'étais hier à la gare saint-lazare
auprès des forces de l'ordre pour leur
assurer de notre plein soutien du
soutien du gouvernement
les policiers et les gendarmes sont en
première ligne ce sont eux qui protège
nos concitoyens les actes c'est
important c'est pourquoi nous avons
lancé le bobo de la sécurité et danse
beauvau de la sécurité le ministre de
l'intérieur
écoute chacun c'est pourquoi nous avons
présenté la loi pour la sécurité globale
qui permet de renforcer la protection
vis-à-vis tripoli conclut claire et sans
aucune ambiguïté le gouvernement
soutient pleinement et sans réserve
l'action des forces de l'ordre qui sont
la police de la république merci merci
madame bois
je compte sur vous pour transmettre à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur que
je n'ai fait que relayer la vive
inquiétude formulée par les policiers
sur le terrain
comprendre le malaise de cette
profession c'est oser regarder dans le
miroir un miroir qui renvoie l'image
d'un état dépasser submergées nos
policiers demandent à leurs enfants de
cacher leur profession ils craignent
pour leur sécurité
pour celle de leurs familles au rythme
actuel
restera-t-il des candidats pour postuler
au métier de policier ou du gendarme est
alors que ferait on pour nous que ferons
nous pour combler les effectifs la
sécurité de notre pays comme un vieux
que des rustines
merci
la parole est maintenant à madame
martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
la crise sanitaire a mis en exergue les
failles de notre système de santé en
particulier le manque de personnel
médical à l'hôpital comme en libéral les
femmes on souffre plus que les hommes
c'est ainsi que 30 % des françaises ne
bénéficie pas d'un suivi gynécologique
cela est notamment dû à la quasi
disparition de la gynécologie médicale
libérale
ce sont donc 23 nil sages-femmes et
maïeuticien qui assurent de nombreuses
missions liées à l'accouchement à la
contraception ou encore aux ivg
mais ce métier attire de moins en moins
surtout en milieu hospitalier en raison
de la pénibilité et de la faible
rémunération pour illustration seulement
1 euros 0,7 de majoration par un de
travail la nuit
la faible revalorisation obtenu lors du
ségur de la santé la loi visant à
améliorer le système de santé non pas à
rassurer la profession
vous les avez d'ailleurs considéré au
même titre que les secrétaires médicales
sans même consulter les syndicats
concernés quel manque de considération à
leur égard
pourtant c'est soignantes et ses
soignants peuvent contribuer à résorber
les difficultés sanitaires qu'il
s'agisse de la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux de la médecine préventive ou
encore de l'accompagnement des familles
lors des 1000 premiers jours suivant la
naissance que vous souhaitez pourtant
promouvoir avec votre gouvernement
pourquoi choisir de les ignorer pourquoi
ne pas entendre ce 5 mai journée
internationale de la sage-femme mais
surtout quatrième jour de mobilisation
depuis le début de l'année ces
professionnels de la santé qui manifeste
pour une juste reconnaissance de leur
métier
et une revalorisation salariale et
statutaire
merci la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué chargé
l'autonomie votre sixième réponse de
celle ci dont madame la sénatrice
martine filleul je vous remercie pour
cette question parce qu'elle me permet
de saluer toutes ces professionnels que
je salue bien sûr tout autant que vous
ces femmes essentiellement bien sûr
qu'ils ont d'ailleurs continué
pleinement d'exercer pendant la crise et
d'assurer leur travail de suivi auprès
de nos concitoyennes la difficulté vous
soulevez n'est toutefois pas récente
permettez moi de vous le rappeler et
nous avons développé de nombreuses
mesures pour tâcher d'y répondre au
mieux
c'est pourquoi relève un relèvement du
numerus clausus a été décidé et remonte
et montre ses premiers effets sur le
nombre des personnes formées et des
diplômés très concrètement les effectifs
ont augmenté de 23 % entre 2010 et 2020
passant de 10,8 1835 praticienne à 23000
174 la profession connaît une croissance
très dynamique de ses effectifs plus de
2% en moyenne à peu près face à la
difficulté d'accès aux soins dans les
territoires que vous évoquez d'ailleurs
très justement plusieurs réponses ont
été apportées dans ma stratégie
ma santé 2022 l'augmentation du numerus
clausus que je viens de rappeler pour
augmenter le nombre de professionnels de
santé la réforme de l'accès aux études
aussi de santé également supprimant la
première année commune aux études
très concrètement cela permettra de
diversifier les profils des étudiants
accédant aux études de santé de susciter
des vocations aussi et d'en augmenter
par là le nombre
nous sommes également en train de
refondre drastiquement la maîtrise des
stages universitaire pour les développer
davantage vers ces territoires
ce n'est qu'en agissant dès la formation
et dès le départ que nous parviendrons à
apporter les réponses pérennes que nos
concitoyens attendent
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
patrick boré pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs chers collègues en associant
valérie boyer qui reviennent du haut
karabagh ma question s'adresse aux
milices de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères il ya plusieurs semaines la
france et l'europe entière s'indigner
d'une faute protocolaire du gouvernement
turc au détriment de la présidente de la
commission européenne mais nous sommes
en revanche resté bien silencieux face
aux multiples exactions commises par la
turquie et ses alliés à l'encontre de
l'arménie notamment depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant
l'azerbaïdjan en toute impunité se
refuse à libérer les prisonniers de
guerre arménien et à rendre les corps
des soldats arméniens morts au combat il
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
la france pourtant liées à l'âme à
l'arménie par des liens d'amitié
séculaire reste muré dans un silence et
dans une inaction coupable monsieur le
ministre
ma question est la suivante que compte
faire le gouvernement pour exiger la
libération des prisonniers de guerre
arménien que compte faire le
gouvernement pour que la france reste au
rang des grandes puissances et qui ne
soit pas dit qu'elle a désormais coutume
d'abandonner ses alliés merci la parole
est à monsieur femme crée stehres
ministre délégué chargé du commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bord et je pense
que cette question du haut karabagh est
si importante si sensible qu'elle
mériterait je me le permet une évocation
des faits d'une façon beaucoup plus
réaliste
c'est faux de dire que la france n'était
pas en première ligne dans la règle le
règlement de ce de ce conflit le
président la république encore la
semaine dernière a évoqué avec le
président aux russes cette question jean
yves le drian ne cesse d'être en contact
avec les autres coprésidents du groupe
minsk riz c'est à dire son homologue
américain et son homologue russe pour
évoquer ces questions
comme il est régulièrement aussi en
contact avec son homologue
azerbaïdjanais et arménien dans ce
contexte évidemment que la libération
des prisonniers détenus de guerre est
une priorité ils sont principalement
arménien c'est une priorité parce que
c'est prévu par l'accord de cessez le
feu du 9 novembre
c'est une priorité parce que c'est un
obstacle à la désescalade durable sur le
terrain de ce conflit et c'est un enjeu
et c'est fondamental car c'est un enjeu
aussi humain très douloureux pour les
détenus et pour leur famille et vous le
savez puisque vous
un certain nombre d'entre vous et tête à
erevan à l'occasion des cérémonies de
commémoration du génocide arménien avec
jean-baptiste lemoyne qui s'est rendue
auprès des familles de détenus auprès de
familles de victimes de ce conflit pour
leur témoigner la solidarité la france
pour témoigner de la mobilisation totale
de la france pour régler cette question
des détenus de guerre pour aussi insisté
sur la mobilisation de la france pour
faire en sorte que les conditions de
détention soit digne et respectent
l'ordre international en la matière et
on peut dire monsieur le sénateur que
les récentes libérations de trois
prisonniers qui viennent d'être
annoncées sont positifs mais ils
viennent et ans ce n'est pas suffisant
la priorité reste la libération sans
délai de la totalité des détenus de
guerre et c'est l'engagement pris par la
france de mobiliser toute son énergie
pour y parvenir
comme elle souhaite parvenir au
règlement en entier de ce conflit sur le
temps long merci monsieur vauré bien
monsieur le ministre vo dernier mot me
réjouissent mais j'espère qu'ils sont
suivis d'effets vous savez les propos
qui sont tenus qui sont ramenés
d'arménie en plus de la non du non
respect de la convention de genève
fait que continuent de torturer
on continue de filmer ont continué
d'envoyer ses scènes sur les réseaux
afin de torture et aussi les familles
arméniennes et ça aussi il faut le
dénoncer
de mon côté je déposerai au sénat une
proposition de résolution invitant une
prise de position en faveur de la
libération des prisonniers arménien ce
sera un signal fort pour nos amis
arméniens mais il est clair que nous ce
ne sera pas suffisant
la france ne peut pas rester neutre à ce
sujet car soyons certains que notre
inaction et notre faiblesse
d'aujourd'hui forgeons notre impuissance
de demain merci la parole est à madame
béatrice gosselin pour le gobelet à du
blick un propos s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité
le royaume uni a choisi de quitter
l'union européenne et le break site a
été signé le 30 décembre 2020 leur
proximité de notre département la manche
avec des îles anglo-normandes est une
réalité géographique les zones de pêche
sont très proches et depuis janvier les
relations maritimes et commerciales se
sont mises à rude épreuve
les pêcheurs ont appris fin décembre que
les accords de la baie de granville qui
réglemente et les modalités de pêche
étaient devenues caduques les licences
d'exploitation affectés aux
professionnels de la mer seront
désormais délivrés de façon unilatérale
par les autorités jersiaise vendredi
dernier les licences arrive pour les
bateaux français de plus de 12 mètres et
le soulagement fait place à la
consternation
car les laissez-passer n'autorise que
quelques jours de pêche et impose
parfois d'autres restrictions beaucoup
de petites embarcations qui ont envoyé
les preuves de leur antériorité dans les
eaux britanniques n'ont à ce jour pas
encore obtenu la licence définitive
un exemple un professionnel qui l'an
dernier en a obtenu un permis
d'exploitation pour les par les
autorités maritimes françaises et
investit 850000 heureux dans un nouvel
équipement ne sait pas s'il pourra
pêcher dans les eaux britanniques la
plus grande zone de pêche aux
inquiétudes des professionnels français
vos services ont répondu le 3 mai je
cite que l'île de jersey était
souveraine dans sa décision qui risque
d'être irréversible et que nos pêcheurs
c'est vrai des mesures compensatoires
mais cette profession qui représente
2000 personnes sur la côte ouest aspire
seulement à vivre de son travail de
boulogne à saint brieuc nos pêcheurs
français subit les décisions imposées
par les britanniques
monsieur le ministre qu'allez vous
envisagez pour que les professionnels de
la pêche ne soient pas les victimes
collatérales d'un bric site qui se
voulait être un accord et qui se révèle
un ultimatum
merci la parole
franck riester ministre délégué chargé
du commerce extérieur de leur activité
oui merci monsieur le président mes amis
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs et
madame la sénatrice gosselin l'accès aux
eaux de jersey est absolument essentiel
pour les professionnels français la
pêche
que ce soit dans la manche bien sûr
madame la sénatrice mais aussi ennuis
vilaine ou dans les côtes d'armor
c'est la raison pour laquelle la france
n'accepte pas cette décision inutile in
unilatérale brittany pardon concernant
ces licences de pêche qui a été prise
sans concertation sans consultation sans
explication et qui crée des conditions
liées à ces licences de pêche des
conditions est également des jours de
mer de pêche en mer c'est inacceptable
puisque c'est contraire à l'accord
justement de commerce et de coopération
et je le rappelle cet accord prévoyait
qui a été signé en décembre 2020 que les
éventuelles mesures techniques soient
basées sur des recommandations
scientifiques appliquées à tous les
navires sans discrimination et notifié à
l'autre partie avec suffisamment de
préavis pour commentaire ou demandes de
clarification donc vous avez raison
madame la sénatrice ces conditions créer
une forme de précédent dangereux pour
l'ensemble de nos accès n'est pas
acceptable en ce qui concerne
spécifiquement ces licences de pêche
et signifie également que nous devons
très vite remettre sur la table à
nouveau les négociations concernant
l'accord de la baie de granville qui est
tombé du fait de la signature du
breakbeat
c'est la raison pour laquelle annick
girardin a pris attache avec la
commission qui d'ailleurs partage
l'analyse concernant les licences de la
france et a demandé à ce que les
négociations sur l'accord de la baie de
granville puisse être entamé très
rapidement madame la sénatrice les
conventions le droit le dih doit être
respectée en la matière l'accord signé
le 29 en décembre 2020 le 24 décembre
2020 sera respectée la france fera ce
qu'il faut pour que ça soit le cas merci
une phrase madame gosselin j'espère
monsieur le ministre que vos propos sont
ceux reviendrons réalité parce que les
pêcheurs n'en peuvent plus merci au
moins mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement ont lieu mercredi 12 mai
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour le débat sur la
réponse européenne à la pandémie de
covin 19 la séance
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur l'antenne
de public sénat
on a le plaisir d'avoir en plateau pour
débriefer cette séance sophie primas
bonjour bonjour vous êtes vous êtes
sénatrice des yvelines et président de
la commission des affaires économiques
et également face avoue éric bocquet
bonjour le sénateur communiste du nord
et vice président de la commission des
finances on va parler ensemble des temps
forts de cette séance de questions
d'actualité mais d'abord on va rejoindre
steve jourdain qui se trouvent dans
l'hémicycle du sénat que retenez-vous de
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement si hatem tout a commencé
par une allocution de gérard larcher
tout a commencé par un hommage rendu à
la policière stéphanie mon fermer cette
policière tuée vous savez il ya deux
semaines par un terroriste et un
terroriste islamiste elle a été tué dans
la ville de rambouillet cette ville que
connaît très bien gérard larcher
puisqu'il en a été maire pendant 30 ans
beaucoup d'émotion chez le président du
sénat beaucoup d'émotion aussi dans
l'hémicycle où une minute de silence a
été observé une minute de silence à la
mémoire des victimes du terrorisme
écouter répondons avec détermination en
démocrate en démocrate solide sur nos
valeurs
c'est ce que nous avons réaffirmé à vos
côtés monsieur le premier ministre est
aux côtés des élus présents vendredi
dernier soyons déterminés
c'est notre responsabilité dans cette
séance il a aussi été question du passé
ni terre vous savez se passe sous été
annoncée par emmanuel mâcon pour accéder
à certains établissements culturels
après le déconfinement certains
sénateurs voulaient savoir si ce pass
allait être imposé à l'être obligatoire
pour les personnes mineures sur ce point
le gouvernement a botté en touche
écouter la fac-ci nation étant fortement
encouragé le pass and i ter ne
pénalisera pas les personnes non
vaccinées contre la copie de 19
d'autant que je le rappelle c'est assez
unique en europe les tests sont gratuits
en france au niveau européen la mise en
place d'un certificat sanitaire
permettant aux citoyens européens de
voyager au sein de l'union est en train
d'être débattue et puis plusieurs
panis aérienne envisage également
d'utiliser ces passeports sanitaires
pour les vols hors de la france
autre thème abordé cet après-midi le
baccalauréat 2021 les étudiants
réclament que ce bac soit passée
intégralement en contrôle continu de son
côté le gouvernement et jean michel
blanquer maintiennent leur position pas
de contrôle continu intégral mais le
ministre annonce est bien quelques
aménagements écoutez le nous voulons
qu'il se passe une épreuve terminal le
plus possible mais en même temps nous
cherchons des aménagements pour que tout
simplement ils puissent réussir
c'est pourquoi il aura par exemple très
vraisemblablement des mesures pour que
un élève lorsqu'il arrive à un oral
puisse indiquer les parties du programme
qui n'ont pas été vues signé le document
a été signé par son professeur c'est un
exemple parmi les aménagements que nous
allons pouvoir donner
nous continuons à discuter donc je ne
peux évidemment pas vous donner
maintenant la suite d'autant plus que
c'est un petit peu complexe voilà des
annonces qu'il faudrait encore précisées
dans les prochaines heures
en attendant et bien la mobilisation
lycéenne continue dans la rue table si
beaucoup estiment pour ce résumé des
temps forts de cette séance de questions
au gouvernement va aller très vite
celle des conférences mais sophie primas
je voulais juste votre réaction tout de
même après et bien cet hommage de gérard
larcher après et bien la mort de
stéphanie montfermeil tué par un un
terroriste islamiste c'était dans les
yvelines qui était aussi dans votre
territoire
oui c'était un image un hommage à ses
empreintes d'émotion j'ai trouvé le
président très touchés comme je les
trouvais touché dans les jours
précédents et je remercie l'ensemble de
mes collègues parce qu'il y avait
vraiment un silence est extrêmement
pesant qui montrait l'implication de
chacun donc c'était très mise très
émouvant et un moment d'émotions à
partager sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle aller tout de suite on va
rejoindre salle des conférences
alexandre pousse à alexandre vous êtes
avec le
au nom du groupe socialiste au sénat
patrick kanner mais oui on va parler des
élections régionales tam puisque
l'information de la journée c'est que le
ministre de la justice eric
dupond-moretti pour être pour être
candidat aux régionales dans les hauts
de france sur la liste de la majorité
présidentielle alors peut-être de liste
ou membres de cette liste là on ne sait
pas encore votre réaction patrick kanner
comment vous analysé cette possible
arrivée d'eric dupond moretti dans les
régionales dans les hauts de france
on est un petit peu permettez moi
l'expression dans le calcul politique
manifestement je pense que monsieur
macron ne souhaite pas beaucoup de bien
à xavier bertrand
peut-être en futur candidat contre lui
aux élections présidentielles donc la
raim s'appuie sur ses très nombreux
ministres c'est vrai qu'il ya je crois
cette ministre dans les hauts de france
et donc ils ont le choix
je suis un peu triste pour laurent pit
rashevski qui est en train de perdre ses
couleurs qui espérait beaucoup être la
tête de liste
peut-être qu'il ne le sera pas c'est un
calcul politique un calcul d'appareils
la république en marche nous avait dit
mais nous nous ferons de la politique
autrement
manifestement ce n'est pas le cas donc
nous verrons bien cela ce seront les
électeurs des hauts de france qui en
décideront donc pour vous l'objectif d'
emmanuel macron c'est de faire perdre
xavier bertrand en ballots de france
quitte à faire gagner sébastien chenu du
rassemblement national ou plutôt faire
gagner la gauche
ce que j'espérais et vous l'imaginez
bien puisque je soutiens la liste portée
par madame karima delli dans le cadre
d'une union générale avec l'ensemble des
partis de gauche et écologistes
monsieur chenu et est aujourd'hui
derrière monsieur bertrand dans les
sondages
32% xavier bertrand en cinq ans
exactement donc il n'y a plus de danger
que représentait madame le pen il y a
maintenant plus de plus de 5 ans donc
moi je ne choisis pas entre monsieur
berton de chenu monsieur b trash hemsky
où monsieur dupont moretti
je souhaite que la gauche soit la plus
haute possible c'est un travail que nous
devons mener parce qu'il ya une
alternative potentielle face aux
ambitions de monsieur bertrand qui ne
vise que la présidentielle face à
monsieur chenu qui n'est que le porte
voix de marine le pen et face à monsieur
dupont moretti qui n'est que le porte le
voir de monsieur
macron pour les présidentielles bien
nous nous avons une liste qui
s'intéressent réellement aux nordistes
une liste pour l'instant qui est
créditée de 20% d'intentions de vote
selon les derniers sondages alors sur
eric dupond-moretti je le rappelle il
avait été soutien de martine aubry aux
municipales en 2008
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer des
discussions entre la liste de gauche
eric dupond-moretti pour battre xavier
bertrand ça c'est la pratique habituelle
de la public en marche et de son
appareil à dire négociés dans une
logique de coucou permanente et on a
bien vu dans la région paca avec eux le
succès plus ou moins mitigés que alarm a
pu connaître en la matière donc ces
pratiques d'appareils sont je crois pas
à la hauteur des enjeux d'une région
tels que les hauts de france je le
regrette pour l'instant il n'y a aucun
contact et c'est tant mieux que chacun
puisse se compter il faut que la reine
que la majorité présidentielle puisse se
compter et faire des scores qui sont
souvent malheureusement médiocre pour
elle mais heureusement finalement pour
la démocratie parce que la rems est
toujours basé sur la confusion des
genres entre ni droite ni gauche à
droite et à gauche et ça c'est le lit du
front national
eh bien il faut de la clarté dans notre
vie politique je pense que la liste que
je soutiens porte cette carte et
politique à gauche et pour l'écologie
merci mon confrère patrick kanner pour
votre réaction
merci merci beaucoup alexandra elle n'y
va pas de main morte patrick kanner
votre réaction éric bocquet c'est aussi
votre sur votre territoire celui des
hauts de france que l'on entend donc
cette rumeur grandit à celle d'eric
dupond-moretti qui sera au moins sur la
liste la république en marché qui
pourrait remplacer comme tête de liste
dans les hauts de france laurent pietra
chef qui je crois que c'est la
recomposition alors qui se poursuit
depuis l'élection de monsieur maquereau
ou la recomposition politique que tous
azimuts on a vraiment l'impression
d'assister à une partie d'échecs
nationale et aussi le sentiment que ces
régionales et départementales sont
instrumentalisées par ce gouvernement
je crois qu'il est temps d'entrer dans
la campagne sur les compétences des
régions et des départements qui sont des
compétences importantes au quotidien
pour les gens cheval beaucoup de grandes
manoeuvres et puis il fonde en parle pas
des gens en parlent pas des problèmes et
dieu sait des problèmes nous en sommes
dans l'ensemble du pays et dans toutes
les régions et les hôtes france
particulièrement encore il est temps de
parler de tout ça que le s'adresser aux
gens ça va être un peu compliqué avec la
pandémie mais il ya une campagne de fond
à mener sur les choix à faire
droite ou gauche c'est pas grave après
c'est la démocratie qui tranche c'est
bien d'avoir un débat clair sur des
bases claires ça me choque pas du tout
mais là on est un peu dans le tout et
n'importe quoi ni droite ni gauche est
nulle part quoi mais ça se comprend
aussi un sophie primas conçoit pour
l'instant dans l'analyse en des
personnes puisque on entend de très
nombreuses rumeurs avec notamment eric
dupond-moretti aux dons dont on ne
comprend la république en marche espère
qu'il fera un score plus important qui
peut que leur empiétera chez ce qui est
ce que c'est inquiétant pour le candidat
de la droite pour xavier bertrand qui
est en plus pourraient s'appuyer sur ces
résultats pour la présidentielle de
l'année prochaine
mais écoutez moi je suis comme mon
collègue d'avis qu'on aille vite sur le
fond ce que ces débats de personnes en
fait il ya quinze jours on se demandait
si on allait reculer ou pas les
élections départementales régionales
certains nous disaient mais ça
n'intéresse personne les élections quand
je vais vous dire si on reste sur les
débats de personnes ça n'intéressera
encore encore moins de monde que si on
va sur le fond et qu'on s'intéresse à la
vie quotidienne des gens moi je suis
assez d'accord avec la rhétorique de
patrick kanner qui dit que pour
l'instant on assiste la part du
gouvernement une politique de coucou ça
ne les dérange pas d'aller piquer l'un
l'autre etc
on a on a vu cet après midi une
formidable campagne régionale de
l'ensemble des candidats ministre qui
venait répondre aux questions qu'on
n'avait jamais vu auparavant et qui cet
après-midi apparaissent comme ça pour
répondre aux questions d'actualité
bon ils sont dans des beaucoup de
candidats qui ont répondu candidats pour
se montrer extrêmement tout ça c'est de
la magouille c'est vraiment peut-être
pour que monsieur macron voulait changer
la politique ne nous avait pas dit
qu'ils voulaient la changer en pire
en réalité moi ce que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on s'occupe pas des
gens s'occupent pas de leurs
problématiques et on leur offre pas d
des alternatives et des programmes alors
au ghana dans quelques régions et
singulièrement en ile-de-france qui
déroulent leurs programmes et
heureusement mais là ce que je vois je
vais vous dire à la fois en paca et puis
dans le nord aujourd'hui voilà moi c'est
pas la politique que j'ai mais c'est pas
la politique que les gens attendent un
mot néanmoins sur effectivement la
situation en paca le cas de renaud
muselier qui était l'occasion d'extrême
tension et hier pour votre parti on
apprend aujourd'hui qu'hubert falco
quitte l air vous le regrettez cette
situation aujourd'hui
bien sûr je la regrette et je pense
qu'on aurait pu l'éviter en réalité
parce que l'eau comme mon collègue je
pense qu'il faut des situations claires
on est soit à droite soit à gauche la
république en marque ne s'est pas
déterminés donc évidemment elle sait pas
où se positionner dans les élections
mais c'est son problème
chacun doit porter ses idées à droite à
gauche et chaque chaque type d'idées
tout à fait respectable ensuite les
électeurs choisissent et après ce qu'on
a vu hier ce week-end j'avais envie de
rentrer dans un petit trou de souris
parce que c'est des énervements tout ça
ça discrédite la politique c'est des
arrangements qui ne me conviennent pas
il y à un premier tour on doit exposer
nos idées et au deuxième tour si on a
besoin d'alliances on fait des alliances
avec les gens qui rejoignent ou pas
votre programme mais en tout cas je
crois qu'il faut être clair avec les
candidats donc tout ça je le regrette
parce que c'est destructeur de la
politique en elle-même et de la fonction
de la politique est une fonction qui
doit rester noble un dernier mot
là-dessus rythme que vous êtes d'accord
par exemple l'un l'occurrence repas
casse accréditent l'idée sur laquelle l
air lr emc bonnet blanc blanc bonnet
c'est c'est dangereux pour la politique
et bien ce type de mélange et c'est très
troublant pour les électeurs aujourd'hui
c'est tout à fait perturbons
effectivement dangereux parce que on vit
dans un contexte quand même très
compliqué on ya une atmosphère un peu
brune qui se développe dans ce pays elle
et des excès des déradicalisation de
tous côtés et qui doit nous inquiéter
nous alerter et adapter l'ensemble des
républicains au sens large
je le dis cette manière là
le rassemblement national est une vraie
inquiétude partagée par beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui faut être extrêmement
vigilant ne pas prêter le flanc à ce
qu'il pourrait porter demain allez on va
parler d'un autre sujet on va prendre
tout de suite la direction de la salle
des conférences pour rejoindre alexandre
poussard vous êtes avec le président de
la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères christian cambon
alors que l'on a appris bien
l'enlèvement aujourd'hui une journaliste
au mali qui a eu lieu déjà il ya deux
jours mais oui christian cambon quelle
est votre réaction à cette annonce dans
l'enlèvement d'un journaliste français
au mali tristesse déjà et inquiétude
tristesse parce que nous croyons être
débarrassé de ce fléau des prises
d'otages depuis maintenant un certain
temps depuis sophie petrona est
décidément les méthodes de ces
terroristes de ces voyous on recommence
et donc c'est une véritable inquiétude
que nous avons nous savions depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines que ce journaliste
avait disparu on n'avait pas de ses
nouvelles
alors bien sûr être à gao par les temps
qui courent c'est assez périlleux mais
on doit reconnaître aux journalistes la
nécessité d'aller aussi sur le terrain
et je pense que il n'y avait pas eu d'
imprudence qui avait été commise
malheureusement toute personne
occidental est évidemment une trois
particulièrement fléchés de la part de
ces de ces terroristes qui essaient ou
de faire de l'argent ou pire encore
et donc je pense que il faut maintenant
le retrouver je vais vous poser la
question qu'on pose souvent est-ce qu'il
faut négocier avec ces jihadistes pour
libérer ce journaliste français écoutez
je pense qu'avec avec eux il n'y a pas
de négociation possible puisqu'on
connaît leurs méthodes
le tout c'est peut-être effectivement
qu'à la fois sur la base des et des
services de renseignements que nous
avons sur place
des de l'implantation des autorités
locales aussi et et des forces maliennes
nous ayons suffisamment de
renseignements qu'ils vont nous
permettre de le libérer
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas souhaiter
la négociation et y compris le paiement
en argent puisque ça ne fait
qu'alimenter cette machine terroriste
mais évidemment la vie de cet otage et
précieuse surtout un journaliste une
fois de plus la presse payent le prix
fort dans ces combats et je me tiens en
tous les cas informé dans le voir dans
un instant nous auditionnons la ministre
de la désarmer ici et donc nous aurons
l'occasion de lui poser la question de
savoir quelles dispositions vont être
prises pour essayer de retrouver ce
journaliste ce nouvel enlèvement est ce
que ce n'est pas aussi la conséquence
des pratiques de l'état malien qui
échangent et bien la libération de
certains jeux aux otages contre l'autre
libération de djihadistes qui sont
relâchés dans la nature
c'est effectivement un doute et un
risque tout à la fois c'est vrai qu'avec
la nouvelle équipe dirigeante du mali on
l'a vu précédemment
beaucoup de questions ont été posées sur
la libération des otages précédent et
c'est une explication que je l'espère
les forces françaises et nos diplomates
doivent avoir avec les vues avec les
responsables maliens
car la france qui produit un effort
considérable au mali qui paye un prix
très important en vie humaine ne peut
pas servir de monnaie d'échangé à ces
tractations et ça montre que malgré
justement tout cet effort français on
n'arrive pas à sécuriser cette zone
notamment autour de gao non bien non
même bien évidemment et fait
malheureusement la présence de
plus de 5000 soldats français n'y
suffira pas c'est ce pourquoi du reste
nous allons ici débattre la semaine
prochaine sur le volet développement
pour lutter contre la pauvreté car vous
pouvez mettre cent mille soldats
vous n'y arriverez pas tant que vous ne
levait pas la pauvreté qui frappe ces
populations et qui est un formidable
terreau pour le djihadisme et le
radicalisme une réponse économique pour
lutter contre les merci beaucoup
président gambien d'avoir répondu à mes
questions merci beaucoup alexandrins
effectivement cette séance a commencé
sur le terrorisme islamiste en france et
on voit aussi est bien bien sûr c'est
terrorisme islamiste au mali aujourd'hui
on parle d'un autre sujet qui a
largement marqué cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
toutes les questions autour du coc ville
et notamment autour du pass sanitaires
éric bocquet donc c'est pas sanitaire
qui va être exigée au niveau européen
pour les déplacements à l'étranger
également il va certainement être
utilisé en france d'ailleurs la
commission des lois à l'assemblée a
donné son feu vert pour le mettre en
place en france pour les rassemblements
de plus de 1000 personnes est ce que
vous y êtes favorable parce que c'est
pour vous on passe liberticide j'ai bien
noté que les députés effectivement avait
donné un feu vert avec avec des bémols
quand même avec toute la prudence qui
s'impose alors j'ai bien entendu madame
bourguignon la ministre qui avait des
propos rassurant en disant qu'il n'y
aurait aucune ségrégation dans la mise
en oeuvre de ce pass sanitaires
attendons de voir jeu j'attends de voir
j'ai pas de doute position très établi à
ce sujet mais la question de fond quand
même c'est la vaccination elle
s'accélère il faut en prendre acte et
s'en félicite et c'est une bonne
nouvelle serait ça a mis du temps à
démarrer mais si on ré ouvre les
frontières à la fin du mois de juin ou
en juillet où cet été tant qu'il n'y
aura pas un maximum de gens vaccinés
dans l'ensemble des pays du monde je
pense
la situation particulièrement dramatique
en inde ces jours ci on sera exposée on
sera exposée donc c'est pas la garantir
celui qui fait gronder des garanties de
sécurité sanitaire c'est tout à fait
légitime sur les grands événements pas
de prise de risque mais
le vrai problème à mon avis c'est le
développement des vaccins à l'échelle
planétaire
ça pose la question aussi de la levée
des brevets quel sujet comporte depuis
longtemps par les 1/4 des citoyens
européens reçu au moins une dose
l'europe semble combler son retard en la
matière même si on reste et bien à la
traîne si on considère les états unis
dont 30% de la population est
entièrement vacciner israël 58 % le
royaume-uni 23% voyait le verre à moitié
plein ou à moitié vide on sait que ça a
été un gros sujet extrêmement compliqué
à la vaccination dont beaucoup d'élus
ont estimé qu'il y avait beaucoup de
retard oui il y avait beaucoup de retard
et on avait une volonté ferme de
vacciner beaucoup dans les territoires
tout le monde s'est organisé pour
vacciner vos coups il manquait qui
manquait l'essentiel c'est à dire qu'il
manquait les vaccins ou force est de
constater qu'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est parti on vaccine beaucoup de
monde tous les jours
moi je suis allé au vélodrome à saint
quentin en yvelines il ya quelques jours
voilà il ya deux mois les personnes
personnes qui se font vacciner par jour
donc on est vraiment sur des niveaux de
vaccination très très élevé maintenant
il faut lever les barrières aux plus de
50 ans ou plus de 55 et ceux qui sont un
peu plus gros que les autres à se faire
il faut y aller je crois que tout le
monde a envie d'être vacciné il faut
ouvrir les portes parce qu'on peut pas
mettre le pass sanitaire qui est
restrictive d'une forme de liberté et à
côté empêcher les gens d'aller se faire
vacciner sanitaire ne serait pas
seulement les personnes vaccinées
essentiellement ce sera essentiellement
soirée d'ailleurs heureusement parce que
si j'ai bien compris ce qu'on comprend
du pass sanitaires il ne sera délivrée
en réalité que deux semaines après la
deuxième injection et à la deuxième
injection n'est fait aujourd'hui que
deux mois après la première donc si on
ouvre à tout le monde le 15 juin ça veut
dire qu'on pourra avoir le le pass
sanitaire magique qu'à partir du 1er
septembre montrent que pour pour ce
corps ont été vaccinées le 15 juin donc
voilà je pense qu'il faut ouvrir très
très largement aujourd'hui la
vaccination
il me semble qu'on en a aujourd'hui les
moyens on vous parlait de lever de
barrières parmi les barrières
rien que le groupe communiste dénonce
depuis le début de la pandémie et bien
il ya cette question des brevets
aujourd'hui bien l'inde l'afrique du sud
une centaine d'autres états demandent la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins pour
vous la situation aujourd'hui plus que
jamais le justifie d'être assurés de
voir ces pays qui est désormais
rejoignent et bien cette proposition oui
mais la démarche on peut que la saluer
mais il ya de la résistance chez les
groupes pharmaceutiques
moi quand je vois les chiffres des
bénéfices annoncée de pfizer enfin on
tombe sur la tête quoi on vient
d'évoquer la situation d'angoissé gens
mourir on déploie les hôpitaux à côté
d'une bouteille d'oxygène et de l'autre
côté on nous annonce qu'on fait des
milliards de bénéfices grâce à un vaccin
qui devrait être un bien commun tous les
groupes pharmaceutiques devraient lever
les brevets et on devrait produire
vraiment partout c'est possible je pense
que la france a des moyens industriels
de le faire avec quelques aménagements
il faut vraiment développer ça attendez
les brigands qui dit ça peut être
contre-productif notamment pour financer
ensuite la recherche sur les variants
que ça va pas forcément résoudre la
situation actuelle que ça voudra dire
que ça fera ça sera pas avant au moins
fin 2022 at il dit dans l'hémicycle tout
à l'heure que il devait tomber pour
avoir un effet sur la production
écoutez il faut il faut mettre le paquet
faut mettre la pression là-dessus
absolument accélérer réduire les délais
on est capable de prendre des décisions
dans des délais courts quand il ya
urgence et là il ya une urgence
sanitaire et sociale et non sophie
primas sur la levée des brevets moi je
ne suis pas pour la levée des brevets
parce que je pense que les brevets sont
là pour récompenser de la recherche les
investissements importants qui sont
faits dans le cadre de cette recherche
en particulier dans le médical
en revanche qu'il y ait une contribution
de ceux qui aujourd'hui ont des
bénéfices comme vous le soulignez une
contribution particulière une obligation
à permettre la production de vaccins
dans d'autres entreprises ou dans
d'autres pays que leur pays d'origine
je pense que là il faut y réfléchir dans
cette pandémique est une pandémie
internationale et sur lequel en effet de
la solidarité de la fraternité est
obligatoire et elle est aussi bénéfique
pour chacun d'entre nous et compris pour
les entreprises ou qu'on n'est pas tout
à fait sur le même sur le même registre
de l heure
et voilà qu'ils ont merdé ce conjoint de
temps en temps ça aurait était
inattendue sur ce sujet la méthode et on
va rejoindre genre gens c'est notre
streamer politique sur twitch tu as
regardé toute cette séance de questions
d'actu avec ta communauté alors
qu'est-ce qui a marqué les esprits cet
après midi ben écoute tu aimes tu t'en
doutes on en avait parlé avant la séance
la question du bas qui était très
attendu et la question a été apporté
dans l'hémicycle par la sénatrice nadège
j'avais on a entendu du coup on a prêté
une oreille très attentive à la réponse
de jean michel blanquer air qui a parlé
de bienveillance et de pragmatisme le
bienveillance sa marche à la bns a l'air
très très bien sûr twitch donc ça a été
voilà ça a été ça a été entendu ceci
étant on attend on a entendu voilà jean
michel blanquer a expliqué qu'il était
en cours de discussions notamment avec
les syndicats lycéens sur la question de
savoir quels aménagements est ce qu'on
peut apporter au baccalauréat pour qui
ce passe dans les meilleures conditions
je te cache pas que ça n'a pas vraiment
levé beaucoup d'inquiétude quand même il
ya encore beaucoup de bacheliers de
futurs bacheliers
on leur souhaite dans le chat qui sont
encore un petit peu inquiet le deuxième
sujet qui a fait réagir et qui a et qui
a suscité des réactions c'est la
question de thomas d'hossus le sénateur
écolo sur la tribune des généraux thomas
d'hossus qui a posé une question en
s'énervant contre ses collègues de la
droite sénatoriale en les accusant
d'avoir eux aussi préparé le terrain à
cette montée de l'extrême droite avec
leurs amendements dans les lois
séparatisme et sécurité globale ma
figure toi que ça a plutôt fait mouche à
1 du côté de la communauté c'est vrai
que il ya une inquiétude sur internet
qui existent de cette tribune des
généraux de cette montée de l'extrême
droite et c'est vrai que thomas dessus
là il a touché il a touché une corde
sensible
voilà merci beaucoup aux gens pour
toutes ces explications autour de ce
qu'elle pensait de la communauté de
cette séance de questions d'actu je
m'adresse aussi à l'ancien enseignant
éric bocquet
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé vous delà
de la réponse de jean michel blanquer
parle d'aménagement possible ça reste
assez flou il a l'air de dire que on va
pouvoir arriver quand même bien
à l'oral à l'épreuve avec une feuille
indiquant signé par l'enseignant et bien
les points qui n'ont pas pu être vu dans
l'année ça vous paraît être une bonne
solution un bon aménagement pourquoi il
ya besoin d'un aménagement les élèves de
terminale cette année ont déjà vécu une
des premières compliquée l'an dernier
avec la pandémie locaux vides les
confinements etc
donc il faut prendre en compte et 100
ans rabat sur la qualité du diplôme sans
en rabattre sur la qualité du bac et
surtout de sa valeur égale sur
l'ensemble du territoire
mais il ya moyen et livrets scolaires de
suivi des élèves
le conseil des professeurs est capable
d'émettre un avis sur la valeur sur la
performance d'un élève en seconde année
et j'avais entendu parler d'une
proposition qui mettait en compétition
entre guillemets la note terminal et la
note de contrôle continu latine
possibilité pour les 100% contrôle
continu non non non je pense qu'il faut
des épreuves terminales pisser c'est la
préparation à la suite des études ses
premiers diplômes universitaires
donc voilà il faut aménager parce qu on
est dans une année exceptionnelle mais
sans rien retirer la qualité et la
valeur du bac
je voudrais votre réaction sophie primas
à ce que nous disait jean tout à l'heure
ça fait mouche auprès de sa communauté
cette question de thomas dossier sur la
tribune des généraux et surtout ses
tacles à la droite sénatoriale sur les
amendements qui a eu la droite
sénatoriale autour du projet de loi
séparatisme oui je crois que la question
notre notre collègue était très très
provocante
il sait très bien que la grande majorité
d'entre nous quasi la totalité d'entre
nous ne partageons pas voilà les effets
extrême droite
du positionnement de la tribune
effectivement de ses généraux je trouve
que c'est une position qui exacerbe la
non plus qui sert pas la politique d'une
façon générale voilà je les trouvais
trop trop exagéré voilà allez on va
conclure ce débat en parlant aussi bien
d'une des autres thématiques qui a été
évoqué cet après-midi et bien c'était la
question de l'assurance chômage
éric bocquet on a entendu brigitte
klinkert qui a répondu à une question de
cas une question sur le sujet
l'assurance chômage at elle dit le
montant global d'indemnisation du
demandeur d'emploi va rester le même
c'est la durée qui est prolongé par la
réforme
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
réponse de la ministre alors que bien
sûr et bien beaucoup craignent et bien
la dégressivité enfin la baisse de leurs
allocations à partir du 1er juillet oui
alors sur le montant global peut-être
faudra vérifier parce que c'est quand
même une réforme exigée demandé par le
par l'europe aussi ça fait partie des
réformes structurelles à mettre en place
maintenant comme celle de l'ordre a si
bien dit plan de relance réduire les
dépenses publiques il reste un objectif
majeur au delà des alternances
d'ailleurs mais au même si le montant
global reste confirmée l'unedic elle
même a dit après la publication du
décret du 31 mars mais qu'il y aurait de
très fortes disparités
on passerait de 1 47 et puis faut
rappeler quand même que les chômeurs
c'est quoi ces 32 euros par jour ces 900
euros par mois
être chômeur c'est pas un statut c'est
pas un avenir c'est pas un choix
on subit et dans la période que l'on
traverse où tous ces plans licenciement
tombent de partout les gens qui
subissent leurs pertes d'emplois non
j'avais choisi cette situation
donc on va ajouter de la précarité de la
pauvreté à une situation déjà largement
dégradées après un an de pandémie sophie
primas ce que c'est le bon moment pour
faire cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage un qui a été plusieurs fois
reportée à cause de la pandémie et
maintenant on nous l'annoncent pour le
1er juillet et notamment sur ses
indemnités journalières qui baisseraient
pour de nombreuses personnes et on le
voit avec un ce nombre d'inégalités que
souligne éric bocquet
moi je crois que dans cette période qui
est une période très atypique très
mouvementée il faut pas perdre de vue
qu'un jour
autre il faudra faire une réforme
structurelle de l'état de ce
fonctionnement d'état d'une façon
générale et de deux sujets très
particulier qui sont toujours polémique
l'assurance chômage et la retraite
puisqu'on a des choses qui sont très
déficitaire et donc il faudra il faut
s'y atteler la réforme que nous
proposons c'est qu'elle ait des effets
de bord qui sont des effets de bord pour
les gens notamment les femmes qui
sortent de congé maternité sur les
contrats à durée déterminée
on sait qu'elle a des effets de bord qui
sont les éveils porte très important
donc non ce n'est pas le moment elle a
des effets de bord aussi pour les
entreprises c'est bien que l'application
du bonus malus sur les contrats les
contrats répétitif sais c'est une usine
à gaz pour pour les entreprises en
particulier d'ailleurs pour les
entreprises l'événementiel qui utilise
beaucoup ces contrats là et c'est pas le
moment non plus d'aller chatouiller ses
entreprises en ce moment de grande
fragilité
donc c'est pas le moment pour les
citoyens c'est pas le moment pour les
entreprises vedettes mais il faudra que
ça que ça devienne le moment quand la
situation sera davantage la situation
économique sera davantage stabilisé
est-ce que tout est à jeter dans cette
réforme des retraites éric bocquet de
cette réforme pardon de
l'assurance-chômage éric bocquet
il ya aussi le plafonnement la
dégressivité des indemnités des plus
hauts revenus la taxation des contrats
courts est-ce qu'il ya quand même des
bonnes choses dans cette réforme
ponctuellement peut-être mais elle
s'inscrit comme beaucoup d'autres
réformes dans la logique globale de
réduction de la dépense publique voilà
le la clé de voûte elle est là et ce en
fait partie donc franchement faire des
économies sur les demandeurs d'emploi
s'est passé par morales économiquement
c'est inefficace
autre réforme j'ai fait un lapsus à
l'instant et bien c'est celle de la
réforme des retraites vous le disais ça
fait partie du package de la france dans
le programme qu'elle a envoyé à
bruxelles et dans la feuille de route
est ce que pour vous cette réforme
aujourd'hui peut encore avoir lieu sous
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron on
entend un certain nombre de ministres
qui est bien dit toujours qu'elle doit
l'être d'actualité mais il est
absolument aucun calendrier pour
l'instant bail et surtout dans je n'ai
pas l'impression que ce soit vraiment un
engagement vis-à-vis de l'europe puisque
on la cite effectivement dans le dossier
qui était remis à l'europe mais en
revanche
ni sur le fond il n'y a pas
d'information ni sur le fond ni en effet
sur le sur le calendrier
je confirme qu'une réforme des retraites
doit être faite vous savez que nous
n'étions pas d'accord avec le type de
réforme qui était proposé et nous
considérions déjà à l'époque qu'il y
avait probablement deux temps un temps
pour mettre là le régime des retraites à
l'équilibré
et puis après si on veut travailler sur
la cohérence des différents régimes sur
leur adaptation et c'est pourquoi pas
mais c'était un second chantier
le chantier réforme globale à mon avis
des retraites il est trop gros à passer
d'un seul coup il faut pouvoir négocier
les choses les unes après les autres
la méthode n'était pas la bonne et
maintenant le tempo et pas du tout bon
aujourd'hui est-ce que l'arrêt fin elle
est d'autant plus nécessaire qu avec
cette crise on est dans une situation de
grands déficits c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure on est en train
d'injecter des milliards donc je partage
le fait qu'il ya eu un côté absolument
étrange d'aller demander de faire des
économies sur les chômeurs au moment où
on injecte des milliards c'est c'est à
la fois faut faire les deux mais mais
pas en même temps enfin voila c'est un
peu comme vous voyez supprimer l' isf et
en même temps baisser les apl en début
de quinquennat c'est un peu cette même
logique mais je pense qu'à terme il faut
le faire il faudra le faire et il faudra
faire ces réformes pour qu'elle soit
plus juste
et puis aussi qu'elles soient équilibrés
et oui eric bocquet cette réforme à la
avant tout pour objectif de réduire les
déficits
si comme en cake que proposez vous vous
si vous puisque vous êtes opposés à la
réforme des retraites pour cette
réduction des déficits mais il faut
prendre l'argent là où il est je parlais
de pfizer tout à l'heure on peut citer
amazon qui fait 44 milliard de chiffres
d'euros d'affaires de 2 euros le chiffre
d'affaires en europe
zéro impôt parlons des groupes français
qui se porte on ne peut mieux je voyais
une statistique sur les dix dernières
années depuis 2011
les britanniques les allemands et des
américains ont augmenté leur patrimoine
de 170% les français 439% voilà il ya un
peu d'argent donc une progressivité de
l'impôt de nouvelles tranches taxer les
dividendes pas pour faire suer le
burnous pour faire participer contribuer
au fonctionnement de la société
donc il ya de l'argent disponible le
gouvernement a fait le choix de ne pas
toucher à l'impôt de faire payer par la
dette
mais maintenant la dette on va nous la
payons va nous faire payer à nous touche
fois ça suffit il ya de l'argent il faut
aller chercher naturellement je partage
pas cette position est évidemment
puisque l'augmentation des impôts ça
part d'un bon sentiment sauf qu'on est
déjà beaucoup au dessus des autres pays
et compris des états unis on a des
formations des impôts qui sont déjà bien
supérieur à tout ce que payent les
autres les autres sites voilà notre vrai
sujet d'opposition droite merci d'avoir
participé à ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement place à
présent à l'audition de barbara pompili
la ministre de la transition écologique
vous le voyez jean françois longeot le
président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable est en train
d'ouvrir cette audition autour du projet
de loi climat et résilients fantasque
qui a été largement adopté hier à
l'assemblée nationale et qui va être
débattue fin juin au sénat on prend tout
de suite l'aide
[Musique]